[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
yeah
all right everyone we'll call the
meeting to order order everyone thank
you sorry it's all
right
here that's all right no we're at 1:00
so just after one so we ready to get
started so
um uh first so firstly Welcome to our
meeting I have apologies for councelor
Barth and Brian some are prepared to
move those apologies be accepted mve
councelor Williams seconded by uh
councilor Becky uh I put that all those
in favor please say I contary to cleare
that car is there any conflicts of
interest to be recording recorded today
sorry I have a conflict with
8.1
okay no further conflicts to be disted
so any
acknowledgements so then we come to the
confirmation of um minutes there two
sets of minutes there some are prepared
to moved by Deputy mson seconded by
Council Ward any discussion I'll put
those all those in favor I contrary
declare that carried any matters arising
from the
minutes all right and just noting
everyone's wearing their Mas that for
record uh Council the W does have an
exemption so just in case people are all
wondering so thank
you all right so we now come to
deputations and
presentations uh first is uh 5.1 hether
Woods of 108 butchers road so he if I
could invite you to come
forward um hello and we'll um there's a
microphone I'll just let you sit and
I'll explain the pro our process so
we've got a um you've got a microphone
in front of you if you wouldn't mind
pressing that when you come to speak and
uh we enable you up to 10 minutes which
will include some may include some
questions from colleagues so uh and
thereafter what I'm proposing to do here
because it relates to item 8.1 on the
council agenda I will take 8.1 first so
then you can be present for the debate
if you wish to is that okay with you
thank you welcome and if you could just
click your microphone and we look
forward to hearing from
you hello thank you for the opportunity
of being here I've prepared a a summary
of what my issues are but since I've
read your minutes I've got further
information to add so I should start
with that first because I haven't got
very much time in your minutes you're
saying that this issue about the dispute
between an esplanad strip which we were
told would apply to us if we subdivided
in in
2019 and 20 was superseded by another
decision in 21 which said that you now
wanted a lard
Reserve this is firstly
um your your desire to provide public
Recreation that has already been
provided for now because you've put a
walking Track up our eastern boundary
which allows ample opportunity for
public Recreation without them also
being given access to the back of our
farm via an Esplanade Reserve I think
you can put yourself in our position
that we are trying to maintain a farm it
is zoned rural
lifestyle we are told to have a a rural
amenity and Rural activities and that is
going to be very difficult to maintain
when you now want us to accommodate the
public on three sides of our property we
already have Butcher Road along the
front there's been breens stock have
been stolen and shot out with bows and
arrows uh hay has been stolen now you
want us to have access to the public at
the side and also at the back that is
very unrealistic the r section 10 is
very clear about what the rights of the
property owners are regarding esplanad
reserves and esplanad strips you cannot
guarantee that you can maintain the
safety of us our property and our
animals when we have to put up
with un
unbridled Public Access on three sides
of our property if you're going to want
the public to take precedence over the
farming activity then you need to bear
in mind that you are changing the use of
that land and you may need to reone it
accordingly next door to us you've got
21 ohoka Road that's already been
favored in the lurp for residential
development so you want residential
development there you want us to be
rural yet you want the Best of Both
Worlds by having the public have access
to our property on three sides that is
what concerns us the second thing that
concerns us is our rights under the RMA
it is quite clear that the council does
not need to take any kind of esplanad
strip or
Reserve we can always
provide in in another way like reserve
contributions and you if you do decide
to do that that has to be with the um
approval and the consent of the people
who've worked for 50 OD years to buy
that property you can't just come in
there and tell us what to do and impose
all these rules on us with no
consultation and no opportunity to
consider the conse quences of your
decisions the reason we were told in the
beginning that we would have an esplanad
strip with access to the for the council
for conservation purposes was because
both David ear and Grant McLoud felt
that the esplanad reserves were outdated
and too expensive for the council to
either buy and maintain it seems strange
to me that there would be a complete
turnaround within 2 years for complete
completely different issues without the
RMA even being
considered we have spent $10,000
maintaining the land down by the river
because the council quite clearly told
us we they didn't want anything to do
with that and we're maintaining it
really well it's been inspected and
Chris Brown agreed that it's been
maintained really
well the the walking Track in
itself is um is alarming because I
believe an impulsive decision was made
at a council meeting to have this
walking Track by looking on a map and
saying this would be nice if someone had
gone down there and had a look at the
site before that decision was made they
would see that the council owns a whole
stand of very old very unstable trees
which keep falling down and the branch
is coming off and a high wind it's
wrecked the fences three times since
they will put up for your walking Track
it is it needs a lot of work done to it
before it's even suitable and safe for a
walking Track these kinds of things
would respond much better with a little
bit more care and
consultation so just just a quote from
the um section 10 of the
RMA land owners have a right
they've got whole a whole bunch of
rights as far as not being having to put
up with public disturbance vandalism
antisocial and criminal Behavior Uh dogs
people theft all of these things we have
a right to be protected from and we
cannot be protected from that when we've
got the public on three sides of
us my questions to the council are why
did you not honor the previous agreement
for us to have an Esplanade strip with
access only for conservation that we
continue to maintain we've let the
council come and go there without any
issues or arguments we've been very
cooperative and helpful why why can't
you stick to that and why did you wait
until we'd paid the council money for a
subdivision consent before you told us
that you changed your mind the second
the second question is do honestly
believe that you
can keep that area three sides of the
property safe when even signs aren't
going to be adhered to if you don't have
any monitoring we all live in this
District we know that that the theft
from farms of animals and equipment is
increasing all the
time why do you need an Esplanade
Reserve at the back of our property when
it doesn't go anywhere you've got the
walking Track which leads on to the
rever reserve which makes even more
opportunities for criminals to scope the
place and and steal stuff in the night
all of the properties to the West are 10
acre blocks so they're not even going to
be um subdivided so that that Reserve is
not going to go anywhere when you have a
look at your District plan policy
3.4 1.1
this also says that you can only have an
Esplanade Reserve if the legal rights of
private property owners are not
compromised and we agree with that it
also
says that you don't even need to take an
Esplanade Reserve if the subdivision is
under four hectares the subdivision we
asked for was not under 4 hectares we've
got 25 acres there it was going to be 10
hectares or more so it doesn't even
apply so I appreciate the opportunity
for you to actually reconsider all of
these points that have been totally
overlocked when you've been making your
decisions thank you hether um I'll just
come to
questions I might start off just uh
couldn't see a hand there so you talk
about a previous agreement what previous
agreement was there
when we were is it in writing yes it's
it's in writing it's on emails um when
we were doing our research as to whether
we would
subdivide we spoke to the mayor and then
we spoke to all the people that were
were involved with what we were doing
they've all changed now but it was the
person in charge of uh Recreation and
property and things like that the first
email was um um from the last mayor Mr s
and it said the reason why they didn't
want reserves anymore was because of the
cost like I said of both maintenance and
uh buying it in the first place and that
was uh backed up by Grant McLoud in 2020
who had the same opinion and when we got
the same opinion from two different
Council people we decided that we would
maintain that Reserve area at the back
and we would keep on looking after it in
a very diligent manner because it was
very clear at that point in time that
the council did not want to have a
reserve there or to maintain that part
of the river we're not saying you can't
come on it to do your conservation or
clearing the lier River or anything like
that
but so when you talk about an agreement
was it a signed agreement were you
talking about an email exchange it was
an email exchange okay thank you and we
we applied for our subdiv Vision consent
in good faith based on those emails yeah
well Mr Mr mad's here so ask him to
respond to that in um we get to that
moment well I certainly will be um
further
questions um councelor
[Music]
Edmund uh thank you hether for coming
along and presenting your case um do I
take it from what you've said that you
are happy with the Esplanade strip but
not the Reserve correct we we are happy
with an esplanad strip which has got
only one purpose because you can have
only one purpose and that is for
conservation and the concerns that the
council might have about the river we
are aware of the fact that because the
river keeps changing we may lose land
that we own to the river and we take
that cost not the council we would be
very happy with that and very
Cooperative with an arrangement like
that are you talking about a 20 M strip
yes or did you have other suggestions no
no and in all the Bits of Paper here it
says that um a 20 M strip was um Wanted
whether that was a
um 20 m is fine next door they took
their because it's Council land they
took their 20 M from the middle of the
river not the bank of the river and we
were told to make it fair and just we
should do that too but if we didn't if
we had to take it from the bank which
may change we're also happy with that
right thank
you all right well there doesn't appear
to be any further questions so thank you
heather for your time and as I've
mentioned before you're more than
welcome to wa I'm going to call 8.1 next
so you wish to just take a seat at the
back um and you're welcome to to stay
for and hear the discussion
thank you for your time um just before I
come to
8.1 um I just would like to move that we
um as a supplementary Council agenda
item um today uh which is uh item 1.1
that came out which has to do with the
Whistler Bridge protection so I'm just
going to move that suppl agenda item be
accepted to be discussed today moved by
Council Duty seconded by Cel Blacky I'll
put that all those in favor I cont
declare that carried so I'm going to
take that item just for members um
information just after 7.1 which is on
the flood recovery uh and um deal with
that
then okay so um if we can take 8.1 now
and I know Council Recon declared a
conflict there so 8.1 which is the espad
strip
um 108 butchers Road I understand Mr
McLoud you're going to be in place of um
Mr Brown today and you're joined by
jured as well thank you jured are you
leading this discussion or is it as a
ground yes yeah I'm happy to lead off
and then um thank you grant can uh add
any additional comments and then we're
both available for questions thank you
so look uh the the purpose of putting
this report in front of you today is to
to um uh request a decision as to the uh
status of the uh um esplanad adjacent to
the proposed subdivision and the St
staff recommendation is that the um
Council acquires that as esnard Reserve
so the purpose of um requiring this is
for as is
multifaceted so the ohoka river River um
is actually a is one of the most
substantial rivers in our district so we
do have we've got the large braided
Rivers um but within the just in the
close proximity of this area we've got
the Confluence of the cam River the Kyo
uh silver stream and the cust and this
uh this River serves a number of
functions um purely from a a flood
management and drainage point of view
it's pretty CR IAL section of Waterway
um overall it has become more and more
challenging for Council to gain access
um to both this River and other rivers
like it over time um just because of the
way development is happening happened
chopping um what was previously larger
Farms down into four hectare blocks um
and I have got experience of challenges
um Within further Upstream Riches of
this Waterway getting access in their
negotiating with property owners um the
so the staff advice is that it's uh is
esplanad reserve we have other areas um
where we have easements that give
Council rights but there's nothing um
that any in any way is the same as
actually the council owning the land and
having full entitlement to access so um
the the other there's there's number of
other purposes of wanting it um we do
actually want to as a council um
encourage Public Access and recreational
use of
waterways um the council has um
initiated the
Arawa process and we're currently
working with a focus on the cam River um
but this is another very important
Waterway uh from an ecological point of
view it's a it's uh is a very valuable
Waterway um has got a constant base flow
of Springfed uh water through this area
um hugely important from a biodiversity
and an ecological point of view this the
stretch of river um and as um you'll
know the council has recently car
carried out a subdivision on the
adjacent land and put
aside um a 20m reserve as part of that
um and also we've future proof the
option of allowing a um a reserve from
the corner so there's actually just
adjacent to it there's a um a section of
the road on the corner of butchers in
ohoka road that has got quite a large
Road Reserve um that's immediately
opposite another section where there's
some quite a quite wide section of land
between the ohoka stream and the road so
there's actually some really good
opportunities for um linkage uh into the
future um as well as continuous um
biodiversity corridors
um and ening enabling Public Access both
to the Waterway um through the section
of land that um has just recently been
fenced off and as well along that St it
would certainly be the Our intention and
staff that strategically over time the
council seeks to to continue um to
acquire esplanad Reserve when the
opportunity arises such as through sub
Vision um so that you can actually get
those uh the important access that we
need for flood control drainage function
biodiversity Public Access um for
walking um and just for general
maintenance and operations so look I'll
I think I um I think council is are
fairly familiar with a lot of the things
I'm talking about and the the the issues
in general um and the report that Chris
put together is pretty comprehensive so
I won't um talk anymore but I'll Grant
if you've got any particular comments
you want to make before we open up for
questions um yeah no I think that that's
been uh summarized quite well obviously
Chris has been having some of the the
more recent discussions um around this
as well uh one of the points that was uh
noted within the deputation Just Around
um stating that we didn't want the
esnard reserve uh that was really at the
time around whether or not we were going
to buy that outside of the subdivision
process um needless to say I think that
that's since been lodged and obviously
that has kind of uh kicked up this
conversation again um in regards to what
uh the former May um May ear had said I
wasn't actually privy to that um at the
time uh as jurs surmised though it's
become more and more important for us um
to actually look at how we do do flood
mitigation and also protecting some of
those biodiversity corridors along
waterways as they become available so
this is really something that we're
quite Keen to look at doing um not not
just here but actually across the
district and especially in line with ar
t as well thank
you thank
you
questions um come to council dty Then
followed by Council Redmond thank you um
just a question please um that the 20 M
strip will that be going from the center
of the river out or is it from the banks
or they
out um it's generally from the banks out
uh the difference between uh I guess the
reserve and an Esplanade strip is that
the strip kind of moves um so you can
end up taking a particular amount of um
land or having rights over a particular
amount of land that can actually shift
and um quite often uh unfortunately you
end up with much less than what it was
that you
originally um had agreed to take because
it's taken from a a very definitive line
um with a reserve you're actually
setting proper boundaries on that so
that it's not something that actually
moves with it
um the reality is is that you can
actually have a walking Track on both um
so regardless it's around uh Public
Access and some of these areas as well
um and it's looking at taking back what
was originally the CH the Queen's
chain just one more question on that
place is it going to be fenced off or or
will the um residents be the land owners
be able to
graze uh generally we wouldn't support
grazing down to uh the Water margin um
but at this point in time we haven't
actually designed a fence or anything
like that we'd want to do that uh in
consultation with with the parties
involved um and also look at how we
do uh kind of just provide the public
with some really secure um separation so
that they also know where they can and
can't
go thank you Council
redmund uh thank you uh Grant could you
just clarify for
me the distinction between an eel and
our strip and an esplanad Reserve in
terms of Public Access if an esplanad
strip it is essentially for
conservation what rights do the public
have over that area if
any yeah it's it's a it's a good
question um because it's something
that's kind of been debated around quite
a bit uh look an esplanad strip is less
secure for um the public and also for
the council in terms of its land tenure
and kind of understanding exactly what
it is that it can own um it gives a
neighboring property owner and the
people that have kind of got some um
interest in that a much greater uh say
on on kind of what happens there in a
higher level of ownership so it can work
quite well in some instances where
there's General agreement around what
can and can't occur um an Esplanade
Reserve actually allows us to put in
place a much longer term Vision around
looking at the kind of planting that we
might do um some of the things that we
want to achieve through the the project
that um Sandra is leading around Ara
tiawa um it certainly gives a lot more
certainty there but it also it it's
definitive around where the actual
boundary line is um so it kind of gives
a lot more uh expectation I guess for
who can be where um and from our
perspective it's uh it's a lot better
from a conservation perspective um and
then also tying people into that as well
with a
strip sometimes it's really more around
providing a biodiversity Corridor um as
opposed to sometimes you can't
necessarily get the public in through
there as well strips can erode away
though and once that happens they're
gone um so if you do have any kind of
natural erosion or anything like that
occurring within there um that's really
the vulnerability around the strip
itself well just to clarify that can
public have access to an eslin strip yes
or no uh I would imagine that they could
yep um and it really depends on the uh I
guess uh the agreement that's put in
place place around the Esplanade strip
when you take it um and you or when you
administer it and put it in place um and
kind of looking at how you can actually
get the public through there as well at
the end of the day the public have
General rights over anything that
Council administers um unless we have a
particular reason for excluding them
from
somewhere uh excuse me Mrs Woods that's
don't Del interjection so thank you
you've had your opportunity to speak so
you just wouldn't mind silent thank you
what would be the main purpose of the
Esplanade given that Mrs wood had said
it doesn't lead
anywhere um is it maintenance
biodiversity what what would be the main
purpose of the
eslin
um look I guess council's not into um
looking at just providing one particular
kind of service uh if you're looking at
it from the perspective of a
recreational Network yes it would apply
it would allow for a walking Track which
we know is New Zealand's number one
recreational activity it would allow for
much greater biodiversity in terms of
actually doing some deliberate planting
in through there and actually creating a
proper buffer zone uh it would allow
also for the council to look at its
flood mitigation um and flood management
UH responsibilities as well so look
there's no one it's not just ticking one
box these things tend to actually um
meet a number of requirements that we
have uh it's originally why the CH the
Queen's chain was put in place um it's
only really through land decisions
during the early 20th century that's
actually eliminated that a lot from
public ownership but the intent was that
it was always meant to be in public
ownership around waterways for this
exact
reason it's it is worth adding
um the don't underestimate the
importance of maintenance for flood
mitigation through this section of the
ohoka uh River I've been involved during
floods having to make some pretty
difficult decisions about um managing
flood water uh in this um in this
specific section um of the river so um
some of you will be familiar uh where
the river Loops back onto um m road is
actually a still over point at that
place and and um both uh in our planning
and management of flood events um
sometimes that involves allowing water
to spill out at Mid Road um because of
concerns about the um flood capacity
through this section of the river um
just gaining access for maintenance as I
pointed out before is becoming more and
more difficult with land owners um and
certainly not just with whether it's the
distinction between a reserve over a
strip or um where we have the issue with
sewers for example where we've just got
we've got an easement that gives us a
legal right to gain access um it's far
more challenging where it's not the
council doesn't have a a stronger um uh
right to access that land so and the
there is there are a lot of trees along
this section of the Waterway so any
Improvement that we can get to gain our
uh legal access into there and control
of that section to have that within the
control of the council which which does
allow um for removal of trees where we
think that's necessary and making those
compromises between biodiversity access
um and maintenance so uh it's it does
serve quite an important drainage and
flood protection
function just before I come to
colleagues um um Woods talked before
around uh agreements that were in place
and looking at page uh 117 of our agenda
4 .1 I note that it's got a column there
around um discussions and then what
staff have located or haven't been able
to locate ground I just wonder whether
you wish to comment on the comments that
made it's page four Mrs Woods alleges
there was a an agreement in place could
you just further elaborate your
understanding please and whether there
isn't been any correspondence in place
from the previous mirror on that matter
is has been advised um there was uh a
letter um which I think was in uh
response to a long-term plan submission
M um apart from that I've not seen
anything from the
primier uh there had been an email from
uh I think myself and Rob Hawthorne have
both been involved in the email as well
um stating at the time that we weren't
going to purchase the reserve right then
um but if there was any future potential
to obtain it through subdivision then we
would certainly look at that as the
trigger point Point okay so that you
nothing further to add from those points
thank you um so I've got councilor
Blacky Williams and Ward I have a cop of
that excuse me excuse me well if you've
got a copy I'm happy Fe the table that
umop uh I'll get staff members to do
that for you thank
you thank you Mr May um Jared and and
Grant have sort of covered my question
um talking about the 20 M thing
um why isn't really necessary to to take
20 M whether it's a reserve or a strip
I'm thinking of um silver stream Reserve
Western end the whole of the strip along
the river there the back of say 8 or 10
lifestyle blocks is only 10 m um why why
do you need more access than a big
machine can get up the track partially
you might have covered that with the
erosion flood thing but in terms of
access
and anything Council would need to do in
there why do you need 20 M as opposed to
10 um I'll just I suppose I one it's
probably worth me reinforcing the
importance of this section of the
Waterway it's it's getting near to the
bottom end of the ohoka Stream So 20 20
m is the um maximum and I really
struggle to think of any
area that would be um require it more uh
given this the the that it is actually
right right at a critical part of the
Waterway certainly for smaller waterways
where they might not be so much need for
for Access you could consider it um the
sorts of activities that we do need to
carry out in these kind of areas is um
would does involve excavators which
which have a Long Reach armor on them so
you are starting to talk about big
equipment not not necessarily small
excavators um and also trucks so often
you're bringing uh material out of these
areas whether that's um beding bed
material from the stream or vegetation
so and just it is quite challenging
working in constrainted um
areas and alongside that you do want to
have biodiversity so it's important
right next to water courses to take
every opportunity we can to have a good
margin um of planting to um allow for
that intersection between the Waterway
and the the land um and also it does
give you the opportunities for things
like some larger trees as well as part
of the planning and perhaps Grant can
talk a bit more about that but that they
have um you know you get the whole the
whole range of plants as well as
pedestrian access um and so so there you
know we're trying to manage a whole uh
number of uses of that land and that
does use uh quite a lot of land and need
it it also does by by making it 20 M
gives you um more opportunity for um
upgrade up grading the width of you NE
were needing to do in the future for
flood capacity or just through natural
erosion of the Waterway um one of the
biggest challenges we have whether it be
a road Reserve or Reserve like this is
running out of room just about
everything and you um you know just an a
top of head example is the work we did
on Flaxton road trying to fit everything
in within a um Road Reserve um it's
always prop proposes a challenge so um
we in this case think that 20 M would be
um you know we do definitely advise that
the 20 full 20 M granted you anything uh
no I think that's been um that's been
answered really well uh look if you take
list you compromise and something has to
miss out from what it is that you're
trying to do um that's generally either
through the planting side or through the
public access um so the more that you
narrow it down the less that you're
going to get biodiversity or recreation
in
there um thank you councelor
Williams yeah got a two or three
questions here um what is the width of
just a normal espad strp compared with
the
um reserves 20 M so what's what's the
weth of a normal strip just a
youngl they're not really standardized
like roads are um so it's really a case
by casee negotiation generally they can
be narrower um and that's you would go
to a strip so you can kind
of you know they could range anywhere
from sort of 5 to 10 m in some instances
they could maybe go up to 20 yeah but
it's not a standardized measurement yeah
my concern is for a truck on a normal
Road 3 and 1/2 M couple of meters extra
for um keep away from the bank which is
only sort of five odd M 20 m is getting
up there um
and the word erosion has been mentioned
several times here if if that River raid
is starting to erode should we not be
doing some mediation to stop it eroding
if that if we got a a major problem of
erosion already now happening um I
wasn't necessarily saying that it was
eroding there but Rivers can and
waterways can erode um we've generally
tried to put Rivers where we think they
should go um as opposed to their natural
flow so it's just something that we have
to consider with rivers so so if we had
a normal smaller strp here um like the
lane owner want just an
esad surely that would be okay if we um
kept an eye monitored it and if it
started erosion we stopped the erosion
side of the um of the river and it would
solve problem maybe and give us both
access
um my my advice is that um 20 meters
will give Council much better
opportunity to be able to come in and
Carry Out maintenance um we're not
specifically saying there's a particular
concern about erosion that was just one
of the examples of the kind of um
reasons uh
the so my yeah my advice is if if you
anything below 20 M does start to
compromise excess and make it more
challenging in the future um remembering
that it's not just about getting a
excavator or a truck in it's getting
both of them in there at the same time
getting them having them able to operate
not have the tracks of the excavator too
close to the river not damaging any
other planting that we might have um or
the access way so it's it is it's always
very challenging and strained in these
areas when you look at the scale of the
plan that helps puts things into
perspective um I'm just trying to get
the page number in the report that
actually shows you the how wide 20 M
looks relative to so that's page 126 in
the agenda um you know we're talking
about four and six hectare blocks um the
impact um when you look at it
proportionally of whether it's 20 M or
something um
less uh still means that it's you know
relatively it's a relatively small part
of the entire rural block there um but
when you start to slim down the 20 m
that does start to have a physical
impact on what you can manage to do
within that area so you're saying we
couldn't get contractors in near a
maintenance if we only had 10 MERS for
example no I'm not saying that you could
do that with a 10 m wide espod Reserve
you could get in and do maintenance and
we do in some other more constrained
areas it's just much more challenging
much more expensive much more
difficult thank you um councilor wall
thank you um how far away from the river
are these big trees that need to
attention that's one of my questions and
the I'll ask that first um I think it's
directly within that Corridor there's
some that are adjacent to the property
um down the strip that leads down into
Butcher Road itself so there's something
that's currently being managed through
the property team the ones that are at
the back there I think the they've been
currently um
the waterways team through Greg have
been going through there intermittently
um we haven't yet as Green Space managed
those trees or or taken them on in any
capacity so would they be 5 m or 6 M
away from the river or they be 10 m away
could tell I couldn't tell you the exact
distance of each tree okay there's quite
a few I believe there's more than yeah
there's there's several Tre there my
other question would be who would pay
for fencing on the boundary to give
security to the land
owner again I'd have to check that with
the subdivision um just in terms of when
you're actually doing a subdivision and
putting that in place um at the point
that you take a reserve
right thank you um I was just uh just on
the acutely place area quite familiar
with that area that's got a espad
reserve as I understand you know the the
width of
that
okay I don't know off the top of my head
um we're just trying to pull it up on
them all right but it's it's it's a it's
a significant distance is it or
not okay um the other is um um just
while you're finding that there's an
email that uh Mrs Woods just T had
tabled Grant I wonder if you had any
comment on that and particularly the
last point it says thank you for your
offer of an espad I just wonder what cuz
it's not the previous email that goes
with it so uh if there was one but
whether it was in response to a previous
email um yep that was in response to a
previous email so that was something
that originally came through uh
subdivisions and property um it was
really a case of asking whether or not
Council would um pay for an explan
Reserve at that point in time outside of
the uh subdivision process um there was
quite a few emails between myself and
Robin Raymond at the time uh just around
that and also John Reed as well uh we
came to the conclusion that we wouldn't
be purchasing it outside of any um I
guess any subdivision process itself
that's really what triggers our interest
in trying to obtain um espan so so the
is there any discretion from your side
as to the width of esnard that's taken
or are you absolutely uh intent on it
being 20 M with I've heard the reason
reasoning given I just wanted to ask if
there's any discretion there as far as
you're
concerned
not from me personally um yeah look I'll
answer your question I've just done my
iometer on the um section of stream
between Bradley's Road and M road that
crosses keatley it's variable um it
looks like it ranges from around about
20 to 10 m um it is it is quite sinuous
um variable a much smaller Waterway than
we're talking about today um I think in
terms of your question that you've just
put
the this um is down near the bottom end
of the ahoka stream so as far as the um
wer District Council goes um within our
district if you put aside the Ashley
River and you put aside the wer River
the large braided Rivers this is a
substantial River it's um the you you
and it's and it is getting down towards
the bottom end of it and we have got
this minimum this this 20 M so any
compromise here it it's I I struggle to
see why um you would think of going to a
narrower width in this situation given
that it's it's probably as far as you
know the value um to the to the uh
Community um is a very high value piece
of Waterway um both in terms of excess
flood mitigation ecological um in
drainage function so um you you could
make it narrower but um but that
definitely would be a compromise um and
as I said I I really find it hard to
think of any other Waterway where um
there would be less importance so taking
from your comments that your your
recommendation stands of 20 M correct
thank you all right no further questions
we come to recommendation uh there's a
recommendation someone prepared to move
Council
Stewart sorry um I didn't hear you sorry
can you use your microphone councel
please sorry it's all right I'll move
the recommendation to
a2e so AE 8.1 AE yes and if as there a
second for that councilor Blacky um
Council Stewart would you like to speak
yes thank
you um a lot has been said um by staff
about the stretch of um Waterway and I'd
just like to reinforce some of the
points there
um and also I certainly don't dismiss
the concerns that Mrs wood have uh with
I've personally heard it many times
before as other counselors may have um
on the silver stream uh when that
Reserve was being developed and also uh
presently on the uh cam River Loop that
we're um we're progressing uh through
our heart Tia but um I'll um the uh
importance of the stretch of river and
its flood potential you'll remember
counselors in
2014 when in fact that whole area
flooded um across and it was a reason
why we bought the Reeves property
because that was severely compromised
and um in that um event and in fact
remains um compromised to be frank with
the um uh the arterial that has gone
through round silver Stream So the
importance for flood protection is there
and as um J has said uh this is a a
river that really can get going and um
uh you just need to sit on your hope
rural drainage group to understand the
concerns of farmers
Upstream now they're concerned about the
huge flooding that occurs upstream and
this is the end point when it um comes
down and joins into the uh casine drain
and into the cam Kaio system so there is
a a real concern uh for Access for flood
protection and also um uh drainage work
uh and as um has been said this um this
River um as far as water quality goes is
compromised uh if you look at the laa
site you'll find it has very high n
nitrates and the nitrates um come from
land use and uh surface water
runoff what a 20 M espad Reserve enables
you to do is to plant um quite heavily
down to the river itself 5 or 6 M at
least to provide a um a filter
strip uh an area where you would have uh
Public Access it may be uh 3 or 4 meters
and then another area um heading up to
the property boundary with um the
neighboring land owner where you can
create a buffer zone again native
planting in consult and consultation
with the land owner to address the
security concerns that many have about
having Public Access around there so I'm
thoroughly in favor of taking the full
20 M it is laid out in our uh our
district plan that in fact that should
be the the width that we request when um
this area such areas are subdivided and
yes it goes nowhere but again this is
forward thinking that there will be a
network of paths and access along
waterways to tick off not only as I said
the flood protection and land drainage
functions but also a revation a corridor
from mountains to Sea which is supported
by our runer and improve the Waterway as
uh that
happens um as I said um I've heard
before um concerns from property owners
who um butt up against a proposed access
way and and putting people through these
areas is incredibly important you need
to understand and appreciate the
conservation values here
and actually embrace and adopt them
because that's the only way that we will
see increasing native vegetation
restored and also improve our water
quality so what I would be what is what
happens um when if this um progresses is
that Council staff would be in
consultation with Mrs Woods about how
those um her concerns can be addressed
and I would say a very heavily planted
uh buffer
strip of native plants and trees would
in fact um
alleviate some of her concerns but also
it is really important that um in in um
taking these strips that in fact the key
thing is public access and people need
to get to enjoy what's been created in a
network of paths along our
waterways and um as has been pointed out
here an espan strip that would be not as
um secure as I think I
certainly with arati aawa um in my
vision but also the council would want
to secure um access and a network of
paths throughout the district along
waterways and as well as ticking off all
these
other uh planks that we want to see
happen in our district so I really urge
you
to uh approve um the 20 M Esplanade
Reserve uh and encourage Council staff
to work closely with um Mrs Woods to
mitigate her
concerns thank you thank you Council St
Council to speak I shall be very very
brief
your worship um just to um reinforce
what Sandra said about the on the
security situation the vandalism and the
theft we have established uh at Silver
stream reserve and other places that
letting the public into these areas
actually completely mitigates the the
the worries and the fears that the land
land owners have you put boots on the
ground in there and and eyes on the
ground um you're actually you're
actually enhancing the security of your
property
people who come and steal stuff have to
bring a vehicle in they don't come up
these tracks the people who come up
these esplanades and tracks are good
good people with good inverted commas
you don't get low life coming up them we
have had no problems in lot in many in
kilometers of these tracks and other
reserves quite the reverse the the
security of your property is actually
enhanced further
speakers okay well do you wish to speak
like make an amendment like to move an
amendment move Amendment um that we
convert that to a um a strip rather than
the 20 minute meter area because I've
been hold on yep so so you're wanting to
amend C is it C to a a STP rather
than change the wng from espad to strip
so and take away the 20 M espad sorry
espad change would Reserve to strip so
you're moving that do you have a
seconder seconded by Council Redman so
would you like to speak to the
amendment yeah while while I can see
um we want a lot of space for moving
vehicles in the a I particularly haven't
been um pushed in the way that we need
that axle width um I can see it's
operating on a 10 m um strip quite
comfortably or and and I asked the
question of what the width of a normal
um strip is and I wasn't given that
answer I was just said it could be
something or something or something
so I haven't been convinced by this
report that it's really necessary for
the council to do I I know it's really
good for protecting waterways and and
and what have you but I haven't been
convinced that we need a full 20 m
um can I can I just make it clear
counselor Williams that all you've
changed is the word Reserve so it's
still going to be 20 M you didn't change
I I said take away the um 20 M no you
didn't said just Reser just you just
said change the word reserve and I said
also take away the no that's not what I
record I'm sorry but that's what you
move say that sorry meing beside me
heard me say that well it's not what I
recall hearing
I did clarify as it was changing the
word strip I actually said twice
actually remove the 20 M well was a
second of what was his
understanding uh my understanding Mr
Mayor was that the word Reserve be
replaced by the word strip and I do
recall councelor um Williams mentioning
10 m I'm not sure if that ended up in
the motion or not well that's not what I
it was significant for me not what I
recall being moved I recall the the
chain from Reserve to strip and that's
what I clarified with you
look I'm going to I'll give you the
benefit of the doubt um if if another
counselor heard it but I heard it
differently so you would want you you
didn't
say you clarify well I think I've
clarified the wedding so at the present
time it's still has the words 20 m in
there okay councelor um councilor um
Redmond thank you Mr Mayor I've seconded
this motion because I'm not convinced
that an e Lenard Reserve is the best
option I think the objectives what we're
trying to achieve can be met by an
esplanad strip as opposed to a reserve
and I just checked in schedule 10 of the
resource management Act the provisions
of an explan strip are set out those
unless the strip is for conservation
only um an esplanad strip can also
provide Public Access uh which I think
is one of the reasons for having
Esplanade strips in the first place
um if it's a reserve this Council will
have to purchase the land in involved so
if we're going to do that over the whole
District there's a significant financial
cost in that where I think a reserve
will actually achieve the same result it
gives the private stri strip sorry very
confusing it a strip does give the
existing owner some control in terms of
the area concerned it remains part of
the title if what whatever the width of
the strip is um it's unlikely to be
eroded so that it becomes useless if
there is some movement at the margin of
the river um
bank I think it's a matter of balancing
uh private property rights and the
benefit for the public generally and
section the schedule 10 of the RMA in my
view seeks to provide that so I think
the matter can be adequately addressed
by a reserve strip which does provide
Public Access and
not an esplanad Reserve better get it
around the right way uh which
effectively achieves the same but has a
higher level of council input involved
with it thank you could just before I
come to further speakers guys our staff
difference from and I realize it's
contained in the report the difference
between reserve and strip what is your
preference
please would you prefer a reserve or a
strip um our preference would remain a
reserve and for the reasons um there's
more certainty around what it is that we
can actually deliver on that um if I
just pull up the the
report and do we in the cola each ofat
is do we normally is it usual practice
for us to create a reserve or
strip
uh we would be looking for reserves um
as opposed to strips there's more
certainty around what it is that we can
actually deliver those
uh the strip we don't get ownership with
that um one of the key things there is
that that actually remains with the
ownership of the uh land owner the
neighboring land owner so it's not
actually under
Council
uh ownership um or Administration um the
reality is you kind of normally would do
that where you were just looking at
trying to um have an interest in a piece
of land but not necessarily create
something for the for the longer term
um yeah it's it's it's rare that we
would take that instead of a reserve if
we wanted biodiversity and Public Access
in maintenance of the land is it easier
under Reserve or
strip again that's down to the
relationship with who actually uh owns
or administers the land if it's under
Reserve it's pretty straightforward that
it's Council um under Reserve strip
that's something that we end up having
an interest in and we can maintain it
but it can also
be uh worked with the neighboring land
owner that they might have a slightly
higher level of Interest actually within
that because they are technically the
owners of the land if we had any issues
with people that have strips versus
reserves in The District in terms of
Maintenance um
or or are the measures that you're aware
of yeah uh look each um each time that
you have a license to occupy an easement
or a reserve strip you an explan strip
it's really dependent on the
relationship between uh the council and
the the particular land administrator
owner um so it can
vary just just to help answer that
question
um the uh I have this issue all of the
time um and it's not necessarily related
to a reserve or a um strp it's when we
have Road Reserve compared to an
easement access or right of way for the
council the difference is night and day
when you're um acting on behalf of the
public and the council I've got a um
section in sewer of sewer up in Oxford
that was on our books to replace a
number of years ago uh we just have not
progressed that because we of the
challenges um associated with dealing
with the property owner there where the
council has an easement it's actually
got an easement so we got the legal
right to get in there
um uh we go out of our way to position
utility infrastructure in Road Reserve
rather than through easements whenever
we get the opportunity um I can think of
a number of capital projects where the
council has spent money to achieve that
as an outcome um and when we're looking
at subdivision consense that's always
front M mind I see this as exactly the
same situation the uh my advice to you
um based on my experience is that a
reserve will give the council much
better control and access into the area
um if you take a uh exess strip which
gives you rights over someone else's
land um you're not in the same position
at all so that that's my advice based on
practical experience um and in my role
over the last two decades at this
Council
thank you um Council M to speak or
question questions sure um so just just
to clarify can you please tell me if the
ohoka stream walkway is that a reserve
or strip or is it a combination of both
in some
places and also further to that is the
stretch of the cam River where we've
just undertaken planting for Thea
project is that Reserve or
strip um the artia section is reserve
not strip um I believe the so are you
thinking about the aoka stream between
between Bradley's and kley and
then just looking at that um that's
titled so it would be whether I'm not
sure exactly what kind of reserve it is
but it's nost us us to live there and
head partial of it so most of it Reserve
except for um the part from milroad to
part of uh the end of with the Armstrong
that strip so there's only a part of it
that strip the rest of it Reserve as my
recollection because I that's that's
that's what I thought and I think that
there's been
some um interesting issues that have
cropped up between the two of them but
now thank you for clarifying that for me
uh Council what did you a question or do
you was spect yes um I a question would
be would it be more security for the
land owner uh with a reserve as opposed
to a
strip uh more Security in terms um what
I'm saying is with a reserve they would
have they would have a potentially um
good fencing between the reserve and the
land that they own as opposed to a strip
where where it's open and um people can
walk through and and have Public Access
uh without it being fenced off
perhaps with the with a reserve um I
guess with the with the 20 M we could
certainly create a fence and a buffer
zone planting um to help provide I guess
uh you know that Visual and also
physical barrier between um people in
the neighboring property uh with a strip
again we have to retain um access rights
over that because we're technically not
the owners of the land we're kind of a a
Le almost if if you prefer
um so yeah I mean in terms of fencing
that off we'd have to go through some
negotiation to do
that okay right any I I guess my point
is there's probably less security for a
land owner on a strip as opposed to
reserve are you are you questioning or
is that your
debate I'm asking I think
um I think the the I I do understand the
question um if if it was was a reserve
then we could fence it but if it was a
strip the property owner could fence it
if they chose it's their land so they
could make that as secure as they like
so I think um the you know at the end of
the day if the if the property owner
wanted a secure fence they could achieve
it under either Arrangement any further
speakers to the
amendment I'm going to put the do you
wish to I'm happy to give you a right to
reply to your Amendment if you wish no F
okay all right so I'll put the amend M
we're all clear that it's just changing
the word Reserve to strip I'll put the
amendment all those in favor please say
I contary no I declare that lost so we
come back to the original recommendation
is there any further speakers to that
right reply councilor
Stewart thank you I'll just say um which
has become clear from staff advice and
that a 20 meter esad Reserve gives all
Pary certainty and allows
for um buffer planting both uh between
the land owner and um any public access
that's created delivers on um uh
ecological um
imperatives and also in this case and I
can't underestimate it being on the
rural drainage group and being um
as as several others have seen the flood
potential for that section of the river
is
enormous so I'm just saying that 20 M um
provide certainty and ticks off as far
as I'm concerned all of the four
relevant um and very important uh planks
of
um of um this um proposal so encourage
you to support it thank you I'm going to
put the recommendation
all those in favor please say I
contary I declare it Carri do you wish
your votes recorded both of you so the
votes of
councelor Williams and um
redmund recorded against thank you will
that motion's carried thank you so um
thank you Mrs Woods you're welcome to
remain for the rest of the meeting if
you wish um but uh we'll be carrying on
with the rest of business now thank you
for coming today
thank okay very unreasonable thank you
all right we will move uh now to um
6.1 so um thank you Jared and uh Grant
but members those have got their name
plates on angle can you turn them around
to face me please cuz I I have the
occasional moment where I just can't
remember who you
are councilor Ward could you find us
switching
it's the it's only been two years yeah
I'm actually I'm actually going to talk
to staff about getting the names on both
sides and they can be at right angles
going have talk s about that it would
be uh no we don't have any oh yes we do
we do yes yep we do yeah okay 6.1 so
Pages 42 to 85 so Ellie and Don thank
you there's been a series of questions
also by um counselor um bar
so you'll address those in the context
of your comments thank you 61
6.1 page 42 to
85 thank you I've just um all right alet
thank you so this report is intended to
update Council and see seek approval to
consult on the walking and cycling
Network plan and Associated
infrastructure prioritization program in
the recently released nltp no funding
has been allocated in the 2021 to 2024
period for new cycleway construction
within the District staff will continue
to work with wahi and advocate for
funding should it become available
however due to the uncertainty around
funding the delivery of the pration
program is now not allocated over
prescribed time
period their recommended option is to
approve consultation and retain the
current Council budget allocation of
49% as this enables Council to
effectively respond if budget does
become available from wot and also
ensures that the public get a say on the
proposed plans and
prioritizations Don we've got some stuff
to
add thank you Mr Mayor um just generally
uh this this report is the end of a of a
reasonable process we have been uh with
the community boards and now for several
briefings uh firstly on the um on
specific sections of the plan and then
also uh on the general plan and then
there has been meetings as well uh
yesterday we received um quite a full
email uh from councelor Barnet which we
have responded
to uh now unfortunately that only
happened this morning and so it hasn't
been included uh in any of the papers
that you have in front of you General
the concerns of uh Council B I think
could be summed up uh reasonably simply
and that she believed that a number of
points uh that were made throughout the
discussions with the community board uh
hadn't been appropriately either
recognized in the report or or or
changes made
appropriately um we would suggest
that there's that would fall into two or
three different categories firstly there
are a number of the changes that have
made their way in into the plan in
response to those um to those
commentaries and so there are certainly
changes to the plan that have uh emerged
from uh both the briefings and the
report secondly we certainly know that
it is difficult to capture everything in
the briefings uh we make it an honest
and Earnest attempt to do so and have
recorded those and largely those uh
points are captured in the second of the
reports we did didn't carry them all
through to the covering report the one
to the council but they can be found in
the underlying report to the community
board uh those reports to the community
board were received by the community
board and um and passed without any
commentary about the notes that had
previously been taken so the appropriate
time to express any concerns about the
lack of um uh the if the if there was a
thought that the staff had not properly
reflected uh feedback then the boards
themselves uh had the opportunity to
look at that when those notes were put
in front of them as part of the
report um in saying that of course we
acknowledge that well we we we would
suggest that this step is only putting
the documentation out for
consultation and that there will be uh
this this round which will now occur and
then the boards themselves again will
consider the feedback from that
consultation and um and make
recommendations through to this Council
again as to what what it wishes to to do
with that information I think a lesson
for the staff will be for the next time
around we will make certain that there
are more clear resolutions from the
board on what it is that are actually
wanting to be reflected and told to the
council so uh you know some of the
points raised were I I heard this matter
or um I understand the following was
said uh as I say it's always difficult
to pick up all of the points raised and
made and some of them may be uh a
commentary from a single member rather
than something that is uh reflective of
the whole board's uh view so while there
is a place for informal briefings uh and
receiving feedback for that I think in
this instance given the um you know the
the the email that we have received I
think we will be better uh capturing um
specific information from those boards
and then making sure it comes through as
a clear uh commentary on behalf of the
board to this Council uh the next time
it considers it I don't believe there is
anything um flawed in the information
that you would be passing today I think
it is it is well reflective of the
conversations we've had with the boards
um and I think that anything that is of
concern to a particular counselor can be
picked up and made sure that it is
captured in the next round as as these
matters are um are further discussed and
debated so I'd really like to recommend
this has been through a pretty thorough
process with the boards both in terms of
briefings and reports and also uh with
yourself and I'd like to recommend that
we move it through to the next phase and
undertake that um consultation thanks
Dawn um because there's been a number of
questions I've just I didn't get the
email until about4 12 today so I've just
and Rosie printed it out for me as I was
going out the door I've just forwarded
you all a copy so I'm sorry well I'm
happy
to a lot of people have been getting
have you all got your emails cuz I'm
happy to give you a few moments to read
over it if you haven't puled you can
have my
copy so just just give you a pH few
moments to read it and and um I'm I'm
satisfied with the answers that you've
given but I just think you should um
perhaps just peruse that briefly so give
you five so 10 minutes to have a look at
it in the me can I ask a question uh
maybe just pause Jo about mainten yeah I
think can we just pause to let
colleagues have a read and I'll come
back to you in a minute so just 10
minutes guys and we'll just have a brief
adoura just for the benefit there was a
question question asked before was there
public still here that wasn't any
reference to um we weren't going to have
conversations with the public excluded
but it was really because if there is
members of public here we've got to keep
our masks on that's the only reason that
that question was asked right so I just
wanted to be absolutely clear all right
so if you just have a read of that and
then I'll reconvene in in 10
minutes you
AIT
[Music]
you're welcome to
stay yeah you don't have to
leave this is um it's a public meeing so
feel
free
okay all right nice to see
[Music]
you um well it could be but it's at the
will of
MERS you can
um she really
no no it was n it's n from
thing
yeah is everyone has everyone read the
document
sufficiently have you read the document
sufficiently cuz if you have that's fine
I'm happy to move up but I wanted purose
of completeness for all to have seen it
right
okay thank
you all right if you
have a few
more but if you carry on
raing okay we
might really you still good yeah it's
all
right
[Music]
yeah I think I think I second that
now just for me your bubbl this
[Music]
time
so
[Music]
that's all right um are we is everyone
complete reading were you still
going CC Redman you still going
there is that email from Dave it's from
um from J came
through
yeah
just just making sure for
completeness I know having owned the
difference between ESP and reserve it
was a pain in the back side I rather it
was a
Reser
don't think she was happy with
[Music]
us oh
just
right okay so um had a chance to just
peruse those answers and thank you to
Jared and team for uh those answers
being provided so um questions
no questions all right so we've got a
series of recommend oh sorry councilor
Williams
Sor
yep
Stuart yeah counc Stewart and then
Council
Williams yes
please um thank you councelor um do you
think in the light of um there being no
funding for um this work at the new
cycle was at the present time that it is
worth actually stating that in the
clearly in the
consultation I know you're taking the
time frames off it but actually state
that yeah for the next three years there
is no funding from Waka kahi for
implementing new works because I think
that needs to be clear raises the
expectation yeah I think that's sorry
yes um I think that is a a very good
suggestion that we'd make clear in the
covering wording so um obviously there
will be plans going with us but there
was there will also be a cover and flyer
we will probably soften the wording
slightly because obviously there still
is Council funding and then
secondly um we're not 100% certain about
where the funding might fall over the
next one two or three years and there is
sort of mutterings from nzta that you
know there may be some of those projects
that come back onto Line within the next
three years so we don't want to be too
definite but we certainly could be clear
about the current situation yeah thank
you I think that's a really good
suggestion and as you say we're not
totally clear with your programs yet cuz
I'm not clear um so when they're clear
we'll be clear that makes
sense Council Williams
yeah are the consultation costs on
involv does that come out of that
563,000 budget or is that a separate
account the consultation costs I think
we've got 50,000 allocated which is
primarily staff time for Ali to Ali to
prepare the appropriate um information
to go into the documentation as well as
our own staff of preparing the um flyers
and whatever um do we are we posting are
we
posting posting out they'll be posting
cost and would normally that um
consultation be um funded by bataki as
well and the Project Specific I I think
it would normally come out of the
project budget which would have that
percentage already included in the
budget it would form part of the project
budget costs yeah so we'll be using
actually our consultation would be
double what we normally would spend
that's
correct okay further questions uh
Council Duty thank you just a
clarification please because it doesn't
say anything in here um when you're
looking at these um different walking
and
cycling
um uh programs and the and those that
have been already delivered there's no
differentiation between what would be
suitable for Rural and what would
suitable for townships you know um like
people would make reading this they
would expect the the whole rural Network
area to be sealed but you've got no no
um sort of Al what what is required on a
rural based one which would be probably
a good chip compared to using that hot
mix and ceiling so just probably just a
little bit more clarify
in this um sure approval we we have
attempted to do that with the grades 1 2
and three
classification um but it's not clearly
shown and we we we I guess it's fair to
say we are struggling with the
complexity of trying to show lots of
different information in a in a in a
simple way um and so you know we're
trying to show things like what grade it
is what year it will be whether it's
there already or whether it's intended
to be there um you know so there's quite
a bit of information we're trying to
establish and get across we certainly
will take on board your comment um I
think the other complexity is it's quite
simple as to what is um a grade grade
one's the good one grade one always get
them around the wrong the grade one it's
quite simple as to what is a grade one
it is a completely separate on your own
Cycle Way the likes of the grade two you
there's actually three or four quite
completely different ways of achieving a
grade two like it could be like we're
doing a pry Street or it could be a not
fully separated and and a Grade Three
again can can often be just lines on the
road or whatever so it can be quite
difficult to and of course the next
sentences we haven't actually done the
full design of each of these so exactly
what type of grade two it will be or
what type of grade three it will be
hasn't yet been thought through we've
just indicated what type of user we're
targeting but but not yet gone through
this so how are we
best providing that service to that user
so it is we certainly take on board the
comment but it might be something we
struggle a little bit to to really
clearly
identify just noting the you another
question well I was just moving on from
that one so um the question is really
what what in in the Public's mind do you
think they're expecting of the foot
paths
Etc
it is a good challenge to put to us we
would hope that for instance if we draw
lines down
um flexton road that people would expect
they were going to get sort of an onroad
Cycle Way Down flexton Road will that is
our challenge to make sure that is
really clear what people would be
getting in different instances we are
trying to do that with uh examples out
one side that show photographs of a
specific type of
cycleway um but again you know that'll
be in one part of the document and then
there'll be a whole lot of maps on the
other parts of the document and it might
be quite you know it'll take a little
bit of work for people to sort of look
at a particular line on a map see the
color of it and go back to a sort of a
reference to see what it is actually
they're getting but that's certainly
our uh intention is to ensure that
people are very clear about what they're
getting
thank you uh a question to both and Don
um noting the question that was asked by
councelor Williams before uh that there
isn't the funding here for M
presently do you think it's important
that we demonstrate that we've done this
work in the sense that it may well put
us in a stronger position to put a bid
to wah for this to be funded orbe it
that we did put it in our NL well it was
in the rltp
just was unsuccessful as it appears in
the nltp do you think this puts us in a
stronger position if we've done this
week I I think it will always be a
stronger position if we have more detail
about what it is we want the money for
at the moment um you know that it's
really effectively we're asking for you
know $500,000 a year and we we'll decide
what we're going to spend it on whereas
after this process uh you know we'll
have our Priority One is this length
from here to here and we'll be able to
tell a much better story about the
benefits of that specific work that
we're um that we're allocating Jim yeah
just following on from that it's also
important to prioritize the commuter
sort of alternative to the car sort of
Route first the recreation thing is not
something W cot is Keen to invest in but
anything that takes more cars off the
road and links communties is so when we
do the prioritization you that would be
useful if that came through
and I just had an email question from
councilor baret uh uh following on for
me fing that she must have got a copy of
that which maps are being consulted on
she's not clear despite asking that of
last month and I I think you did clarify
that in the answers before but could you
just she did make that point at the last
um uh meeting before this was laid on
the table and the difficulty again as we
we' actually got about three different
stories to tell so the first story is
what is the overall Network we want for
our district and so that will that will
be a series of maps that show the full
and extensive network plan that we
intend to deliver over time the second
series of maps is okay now that's that
what you want what have you already got
already so then there's a series of maps
which show what we've got and the gaps
in terms of getting to where we want to
be and then there's another series of
maps which so and this this is the
prioritized order of filling those gaps
so there won't be one map that goes out
or one series of maps there is a story
to tell to bring people along the way
will not just be going out with we want
to build this from here to here next
year but that will be part of the story
how we do all of that is a really good
challenge to to to put to us and we're
still working our way with our graphic
designers about trying prepare this
information in such a way that we can
tell quite a complex story but in a
relatively simple way that won't lose
people partway through okay any further
questions you got a question y thank you
I got a question around the fact that so
we're going to go out to consultation on
something we have no money for except
for what's in the in the uh in our own
budgets that we don't know what it looks
like and we don't actually have design
for you to go out to the public is that
my
understanding we are not going to have
detailed designs of each stretch we are
going out to ask them the ex in
particular you you've raised a good
point which we as staff asked ourselves
when we've heard the funding was pulled
is should we pull this consultation all
together uh are we going to ex uh
generate expectations that that we can't
meet I think the main benefit of
continuing to go
is we has as of we as staff have
struggled over the last 5 years or more
whenever we are doing upgrade works of
trying to think about what are the cycle
implications of this works we've just
had those conversations with Flaxton
Road uh upgrade we've had the
conversations with flexton fernside
roundabout soon we'll be having them
when we talk about fernside towns end
intersection um fern inside Lan's
intersection unless we as a community
decide where we want our cycle links to
go uh until that time every time we
upgrade a section of Road we'll be
questioning to ourselves as what are the
cycling impacts of this so I think
regardless well so the first thing is I
think we do need to adopt a cycle
Network plan which shows which roads
we're intending to concentr trate our
cycl on or allow for our cyclus on or
whatever the right terminology is beyond
that it is a valid question to say okay
if we've got no money what's the next
part of the story we're still hopeful
that by getting a prioritized list we
are in a good position to either fund it
ourselves or when wakah money does
become available uh to to to respond
that but it is a tricky message to go to
the public with we 100% agree with you
on that is that uh people are going to
say exactly the same as you why are you
coming to us if you got no money okay
all right so um no further questions I
think we'll come to Y I'm sorry I just y
clarify something sure no so so if we
voted to retain the
5635 that we've put into the budget for
the next 3 years so am I correct in
assuming then that that any works that
we did on our own was without subs
subsid subsidization from Waka kotahi
would then never be available would
never be um able to be um supplemented
by Waka kotahi if in fact they do make
an about face on on funding any of
these so that so so we would essentially
be spending um you know
yeah yes the the the work that had been
completed we couldn't go to them
retrospectively and say can we have
please have 50% any from the date they
freed up that money then that would be
for subsequent things yes that were
undertaken yes it's really disappointing
that's correct thank you okay um so
there's a recommendation someone
prepared to move move to councilor Ward
seconded
by uh councilor redmund do you wish to
speak councilor
Ward um yes I do I think this is
important to have it have it um have
this in in there so that we can we've
actually um can use that to to um show
that we're sincere about um improving
our walking and cycling Network in the
region and also when we're doing um
developments that that are included and
we can push because we've got the plan
we can push forward and hope that we get
um our monies from the government to
assists to do it so if we don't have it
you're not going to get it so I think we
have to keep moving
forward C
Redmond thank you Mr may as a noted
proponent of cycling I'd like to
congratulate you on the plan um and I'm
tongue and cheek when I say I'm a noted
cycling proponent um but I would like to
congratulate you on your consultation
this is the fourth or fifth time you've
engaged with me on this so I feel I know
rather well and um I can speak from
experience with the Woodin and community
board we did make a point and that
Point's been adopted in the
program so from my point of view I don't
think you were simply ticking a box um
and I agree I thought you were both
listening to what feedback you were
receiving and it's been a very timec
consuming process I would have thought
to go around all the community boards
talk to the C and briefings come along
here again um so I I think there's so
much work going on that I'd like to see
it continue to
fruition so once again thank you very
much and in particular Ally I think
you've grown in confidence at these
various presentations and I've noticed
that so well done thank
you thank you um councilor Williams and
meetings and counc Redman does have a
bike it's just still in the
box
sorry
C whilst I think it's very important to
have a strategy of where all their cycle
lanes and and what have you go around W
Mak it is very important but I don't buy
into that situation by having these
plans will make it easier for funding
because the way I see it um normally the
government and wakaki as the ones that
actually want us to put in these cycle
ways and are pushing that so they have
withdrawn their funding from the
council we're going to be up for double
the cost of our um consultation from the
rap pars without getting any leverage
back from the government and it they
been the ones that been you know funding
it or 50% funding it with us before and
and theyve pulled the pin on it which is
um I'm I'm not in favor in some of these
cycle ways would go everywhere I notice
in Orland they're removing some of them
but um I think it is important for us to
actually have a cycle Network to know
where we're going and um when New Roads
particularly get put in we've got
linkage from those New Roads um to
existing cycleways and you know for a
longterm thing and I while I will
support this I'm very disappointed with
the government pulling funds so it makes
our future planning very sick and you
know for future planning it just it
doesn't look really
good got some
meetings um first off I again I would
just like to say thank you for the
comprehensive process that you've
undertaken doing this you've spent a lot
of time and effort to go and speak to
all the community boards and and with
the working group and and whatnot to
actually come up with this plan and you
know it is important like you said for
us to have a plan and on that basis I
can support the recommendation for the
fact that I believe that we do need to
actually demonstrate we have just
thought we have thought about this we
haven't just pulled it out of nowhere
but I find it really disheartening and
very extremely disappointing that Waka
kotahi for all of their spit and Bluster
for saying that they they want to get us
out of vehicles and into alternative
active modes of Transport that they have
withdrawn the
51% um subsidy that that funds these
things they have indicated to us that
they're focusing on
that they want to focus on alternative
modes of Transport which we've done and
they've still pulled the rug out from
under us and I find it particularly
upsetting for the fact that in the rural
areas that do not have public transport
at all none even the one bus that went
to Oxford has been
discontinued um just just basically to
get children safely down 100K very busy
road to to a school we have nothing to
go with that and you know there there is
an expectation and a desire by our
communities to at least give kids that
that are outside of the school bus um
catchment area because if they live
closer than 3.2 or 4.8 kilometers from a
school they're not eligible for school
bus those guys are left high and dry by
this and our community you know has has
a Justified expectation that you know
something should be done and in that
area and we we've tried to do that and
the nzta has completely let us down and
so whilst I will vote for this I am very
very disappointed it's absolutely
disgusting that they have just
completely hung us out to
dry thank you just just to add uh
support the comments that have been made
uh and look and agree entirely with
councilor redmund I think Allie you've
done a really excellent job through this
process and it's through that uh that we
have got through and there's all this
work that's been done that I'm going to
support us going out to um consult with
our
community and and Don it will be a bit
of an act of how we explained that I um
but I do in my question before it was
around demonstrating that the work um
could be done and has been done would
put us in a stronger position we've
invited and in fact have had accepted
chief executive of wahi coming here
shortly uh and so it gives us a stronger
position in which to um make that point
to say that we're actually going out and
this is one that we are very
disappointed in I understand the bridge
in Oakland has been cancelled this is700
odd million dollar being freed up one
would assume that's come from well a
source that could be
redistributed so it may well be that we
end up we end up in a position um
through this because I the NLT Pro nltp
processes we've previously said has been
disappointing this round and what we
haven't gotten there including the I
think it was the 1.5 million that we
were looking at to match our funding uh
for this Pro uh program here so uh it is
really disappointing however all the
work's been done it's not worth shelving
um when a lot of work's been put put in
put this in the position now to go out
have that conversation with our
community and then it'll be up to to us
uh what we PR prioritize going forward
and hopefully we've been in a position
to persuade W kahi to provide us some
funding so thanks team any further
speakers Council Stewart thank you um I
just want to um endorse what's been said
before but I think it's absolutely
essential that this goes out for
consultation um not only because of the
huge amount of very excellent and
detailed work that's gone on um but it
gives us certainty and future Road
planning and I think particularly in
rural areas and I think it was I don't
want to face a Pari Street ever again uh
where you're
retrospectively um and undoubtedly it
might happen but we retrospectively
trying to uh bring public on board um
for uh a cycle link that we deem to be
um
essential here we need to um do our new
roading and cycle um provision uh hand
in hand and from this consultation I
would say that we would be able to see
clearly and I would like to think that
the rural community really um gets up
and bus like several dogs on this
because um that will enable us to um put
the case um uh to wahi um if and when we
get the opportunity that really we we
have a part of our community that has no
public transport and um no safe way as
Council mining has said of getting um
kids to school and um we do need their
support the community support uh in
changing some Minds about um going
forward with um projects like rural
cycle networks so I think it's essential
that this goes out and we hear from our
community about um what they want and um
just encourage um
encourage everybody around the table to
support this thank you uh Council ainson
thank you Mr may come no to no surprise
that I won't be supporting this um I
mean I I just think this needs to go on
the Shelf there's no funding for
something we don't know about we don't
have a design we don't have all of these
things that that we need to make
decisions for not to be able to do
anything I mean the way we spend money
500,000 over the next 3 years in our
budget will go from this corner here to
the main street and you'll build a
cycleway that'll be the size of it and
it's all over sorry nothing else to come
with no future funding we've got a plan
that's that's in here know it hasn't
been to the community but if we're going
to bid we need to be doing that long
before we spent $50,000 to go out on
something we don't know
about and it's ridiculous ABC roads a
dumb
idea nothing wrong with designed roads
within our roads but but we don't have
with the public an ABC or a 123 or a
whatever you call it to the public I
mean Don's just stated that it's going
to be terribly confusing and and hard to
get consultation to our public we don't
understand I don't understand this thing
I mean they're not going to where's it
going to be where's it going to come
What's the timing going to be and we're
going to go out to consultation on this
very rarely do you ever see me vote
against something that's going to
consultation the timing's wrong
yes we've done a lot of work and it'll
still be there when and if the funding
comes
up the one thing that I'm extremely
disappointed in and I've sat around this
table and sung it for I don't know how
long and at the gcp table we're not
talking about walking and cycling we're
talking about alternate transport
means but all we talk about is walking
and cycling tracks that's not what we've
got it's not what we want we want
alternative cycl alternatives to driving
your
car we've got we're going to have what
I'm envisaging and I don't know this for
sure because I don't know what the ABC
is going to be but if the a is the
best then we got 400 MM between a road
at 60 K down here outside Howers and
down through that comes up to the start
of kway 400 MM of grass on a separate
separately built cycle and walkway
that's safe isn't it yet we were told
that couldn't be done uh we couldn't go
Offroad yet have a look at the cycle way
that comes from Christ Church past fan
fear all the way to get to our un our
dangerous piece we're just creating it
again I won't support it okay further
speakers write a reply Council Ward if
you wish to exercise
it no I'm I'm going to support this
because I think that we um need to keep
moving on this and and so I'm going to
support okay going to put the
recommendation uh is through the order
paper all those in favor please say I
cont no recorded please declare that
Carri and council ainson is recording
his vote um opposed thank you all right
thanks Al and Don good
work okay now come to um item seven uh
Co 19 uh planning shovel ready projects
um
I think we've that's going to be covered
off a 19.2 so um
7.1 uh so 19.2 yes it is sorry pardon me
19.2 which is in the PX I was thinking
where is that in the agenda um 7.1
will'll come to that Simon now so uh it
does say in the order paper May 21 flood
recovery uh termination report and the
report it says completion so just note
that termination
we did pick that up at management at the
time that's how desperately we want this
thing to end I suppose um thanks that is
completion is the correct word uh thank
you Mr Mayor and councilors uh so this
this report really does signal the
completion of the the coordinated
recovery phase for the May uh flood
event and I note that um uh activities
and Recovery will still continue but
under business as usual uh Arrangements
uh particularly in our UNR department
where Jared and his team have uh
continued to integrate some of the um
ongoing repairs from this event into
their work programs and you will recall
the um uh the presentation and report
that came to September meeting from
Jared which listed and highlighted all
the activities of the uni Department in
relation to this and that is an
attachment to this
report uh just also wanted to note very
quickly that the mural Relief Fund from
which we gained around
$55,000 in total has uh more or less now
all been spent we've made the final we
will be making the final allocations of
a few th000 this week um and that's gone
out to support largely those in our
rural communities but there have been
some others that have been supported in
wuku and the likes uh as
well uh the table in 4.15 captures some
of the learnings observation and
opportunities that I think we should be
carrying over and continuing to think
about uh through what we call Peace time
and um and thinking about that more
specifically as part of a uh an updated
and renewed recovery plan a generic
recovery plan or Arrangements that we
seek to continue to build in the
background and it's likely that this
will result in us coming to the annual
plan process with a bid for a small
amount of money to help us with the
development of that
plan um just wanted to note uh some
information that came through just
recently following the completion of
this report and it's it's from uh MPI
and it and it referred to the amount of
money from the $4 million appropriation
that was allocated to farms in our
district and you might recall that um to
be to qualify um as a farm you had to
derive 51% or more of your income from
that land and that allowed you to get
access to uh applying for some of that
money from the MPI appropriation the $4
million and also task force green help
if you didn't make that threshold then
you were considered uh for this event as
a lifestyle block owner and um the best
means of support that could be provided
was through the maril relief fund and uh
notwithstanding insurance and and the
like if you had that overall our
district to date from the MPI fund has
only attracted
$20,000 across the proper properties
that we've had um and the mural Relief
Fund uh allocations have been up to
55,000 as as described before so we've
we've assessed more than 60 rural
properties some of those properties
would have had damage individually that
is well and excess of that amount um and
so we do need to think about and and the
point of that comment is that we do need
to think in peace time about what are
the uh risk reduction event Readiness
and resilience type activities that we
need to continue on planning for so that
in future events uh our communities are
better prepared for for these things it
also notes that whilst um the
politicians were highly interested in
this event the actual amount of funding
that hit the ground was was relatively
light in relation to the amount of
damage that
occurred um we also need to note that
with the frequency of these events
increasing the chances of um
simultaneous events and overlapping
events is probably more likely and this
is a good example of that where we had a
Canterbury event followed very closely
by a Westport event followed very
closely by Resurgence of coid and so uh
when we talk now to National agencies
about the canbridge blood event um their
their mind is Elsewhere on other things
so uh we do need to think about risk
reduction resilience building and um
event Readiness uh going forward and and
that's why encourage you to support when
we come back to you through the annual
plan process the continued preparations
that we make through this recovery plan
um but look more than happy to take
questions from counselors uh on on the
report or any activities that were
undertaken through the course of the
recovery thank you I might just add
briefly just around the M um Relief Fund
can I just acknowledge the support of
staff that uh assisted with the guidance
uh both Simon and Brenan and Tissa uh
and also uh de Atkinson who assisted me
in the decisions I personally think it's
really important that it isn't just a
decision I solely make that it's made
with advice and guidance and Simon I it
be I think whilst you're saying this is
the completion report perhaps we need to
um just do one further B piece of
business which is to report back to the
council how that mural Relief Fund was
allocated through that time and to whom
and that may be something we we can
whether that's in um um public or PX
depending on the information that's
there but I I would like um as a
completeness to to report back on how
that was allocated as we did receive um
uh in addition to the uh funding from
the crown we did receive um two grants
from um private individuals as well or
business and um in another Council
actually um so it would be good to just
to complete that thank you really good
report questions coun Duty
sorry just a question please from the
NPI did they not um consider the fencing
that that has been requested to for um
to fence off streams did they not
consider that worthy of um perhaps
replacement I mean that's hundreds of
thousands of
dollars um early on in the announcement
of the uh 4 million appropriation um it
was perceived that applications could
could be um could sort uh support for a
number of activities and as time went on
I think the nature and scale of the
likely applications became better known
and the the criteria was um reduced back
to largely debris that washed on to
properties houses from from rivers and
and a few other things which greatly um
changed what land owners could actually
apply for and there were a number of
applications that did not meet that
criteria and therefore we're not funded
I understand that there's a a a sum of
money still um in that fund to be
allocated uh and there is a bit of a
review going on as to whether that those
um criteria will be loosened um but we
do need to also consider that this is a
regional event and um there were uh
districts that were significantly harder
hit uh with much greater damage than our
own in this event um and so um that
money would be eaten up very very
quickly if they open up that criteria I
think yeah and and just for your we did
argue that uh in Pita to the Prime
Minister and um and others and if
actually came and met with us and we put
those points the rural support trust
also back that with winon Delhi and they
really do need to review the the whole
terms of um lifestyle in in rural
property because it's not fair how
that's been determined and you're
absolutely right Council Duty that the
fencing is one of the largest costs in
fact Farmers up in Le Valley one farmer
in particular was telling me that he's
got half a million dollars of fencing
cost and it's just not in well may be
insurable but the cost of having the
premium are another matter so uh and for
exactly the point we raised around like
riparian and other plantings which had
already happened was to so anyway other
events came along like um co uh and
other things so some of that Focus went
went and went away and blam's floods as
well in the sorry the coasts
particularly so the focus went off our
area um at that time unfortunately
because the it was as Simon observes we
had God multiple politicians through
that were making all the right noises
but all of a sudden the focus went
elsewhere anyway we did try yeah y I was
fortunate on uh Thursday or Friday to
attend the task force green um thank you
barbecue that they had after the spend
and just on what you're were saying um
certainly around doc
um conservation for um can't remember
their full
name um and the groups that were already
the we have task for screen within that
that operated with Under The Umbrellas
of these groups was certainly talking
about the fact that um they would like
the fund that you were talking about
before to be opened up a little so that
they could continue on they have a
number of people that have um worked for
task force green through this and in
fact while I was there there was um uh
three of those young people who actually
said that they had job office in front
of them because of what they done um
during the uh during the floods but they
were trying to uh uh what they were
going to try and do was see if they
could get that fund opened up so they
could go out and they may not pay for
the fences but may be able to offer the
labor to be able to put the fences back
in so that's not dead as yet because
that is still going through but it's
driven from a different area rather than
the area of councils and things that's
actually driven by the people who have
run the task force green
operation okay thank you any further
questions so we got a series of
recommendations some are prepared to
move moved to councilor Atkinson
seconded by councilor Williams you wish
to speak I just say look it's whenever
you're dealing with any disaster and
you've got some funds that need to be
distributed and things it's it's always
a difficult task there's never enough
for anyone to go around and um I mean
we're no different to the government um
they may have had something that was
pretty there was a fund that they had
there that was finite we had exact we
had a piece of that was was also finite
and and extremely difficult to um uh to
decide where that should go I think
everybody that's in the way of that
water was pretty much in need but uh
unfortunately couldn't get there but I
do want to acknowledge the the uh four
hectare block owners and that uh there
needs to be far more recognition um of
those areas um in the future for these
sorts of events far more common than
they ever
were councelor
Williams
F the
speakers Simon great report great work
and we we had a really good debrief um
uh with colleagues about a week ago so
there's been plenty of opportunities but
there been a lot of uh effort going to
this so thank you um for for U the work
that's been done and you can transition
back to your baau now um you're
officially almost
completed all right we'll put I'll put
this you wish right put that all those
in favor please say I contrary to clear
that carry thank you um we now can we
come to the we're going to come to the
supplementary agenda item now which is
uh Joanne and Don is it just is Joanne
joining us today so um I think this has
been integrated into the
a yeah it I'm just trying to remember
uh
anyway I I have read the report I just
can't find it in here anyway um John if
you could take us through the report and
uh not any points you wish to to make
thank
you uh thank you Mr M I I won't SP very
long on this I think it's fairly
self-explanatory after the floods uh
Whistler was washed out uh quite badly
on both sides took quite some time to
get it open again because we could get
just just a pause for members trying to
find it it's and if you go back out of
your main report um back into all
committees go along it's under
supplementary agenda item was the bridge
sorry Don I just U thank
you um uh the the bridge was reinstated
probably about a month after the event
uh when we could get the heavy machinery
in there however it hasn't had its
permanent uh uh protection um installed
as yet a main cause for that was the
uncertainty of of the funding uh and
just making sure how you know how we
were going with all of that um we just
determined exactly how we were going to
do it um about 2 days before last flood
which occurred um about two weeks ago or
a week and a half ago uh and washed out
the bridge uh a small uh wash out of the
bridge again that uh led to a more
focused meeting on site where we really
did did reconsider I suppose the more
traditional um methods uh that have been
used in the past and in particular one
of the scyon uh long-term um
Representatives Mike Powers was standing
there saying um you know this will be
about the fifth time I've put gabian in
at this bridge um and when you look
there there's there's nothing to see
there's no gabian there's no nothing so
that did um cause us to stop and think
about other Alternatives we the bridge
uh the ship and container option has
been sort of bounced as a as a as an
idea but not really gained traction um
for some time um but we did in light of
what's Happening up there we did give it
some uh more careful
consideration uh and so in doing that we
um got the contractor to price it up uh
we spoke to Ean about uh about it um and
we also spoke to Waka kahi and of course
um Joanne and and Jared as well and the
end result has been we do have uh
funding and Technical agreement from
wakah uh and we do have um agreement and
principle from Ean although there is a
retrospective conscent um expected
afterwards uh we believe it's going to
be a pretty robust system we will have
open topped containers we'll fill them
with gravel um and we also believe we
and we will wire rope them together
together so they act uh together we also
believe we can mitigate any visual
effects we'll have gabian uh on top and
we'll Bank the gravel up against the
front face as well as uh beding the
things in at least to half the depth
below uh riverbed level um so all in all
we think we've got a a good robust
solution B um a cheaper solution uh and
C we can mitigate any visual effects um
I also included reference of this to the
latest update to the residents uh the Le
Valley residence um and I haven't had
any negative comment back about that um
you know we're aware this could be seen
in a negative light um it you know could
seem a little bit Half Baked um but
we're pretty determined to make sure
that you know that doesn't uh give that
appearance uh this is a high natural
values area uh and so of course we don't
want to put anything in there that is
going to um you know be a negative uh
impression um but the most important
thing to us is to get that bridge in
such a state that it um it's not going
to wash out as regularly as it has done
uh costing us a lot of money uh each
time that happens and and disrupting the
um the accessway up there so without any
further Ado uh I'm happy to take
questions okay I cancel said
sorry Williams Duty and bling thank you
yep don't just um the containers
themselves I mean they will Rust so how
long do you expect them to last as a as
a container if you like to to hold stuff
I mean is is this just a until it
stabilizes itself once it's in there and
the containers are gone and then it
doesn't matter or is it something that
in I don't know pick a time the
container is going to rust in 10 years
time going to start again and do it
again or is it is it just unknown it is
unknown to be honest I'm I'm expecting
more like you know 30 40 years uh a good
long-term solution we are expecting uh
we will be cutting uh um holes in the
bottom to make sure they they drain
appropriately uh and don't fill up um
probably the most uh aggressive portion
will be on the front face where we are
only pushing up gravel which will wash
away when we get a decent fresh and then
the gravel you know will probably give
it a good sand blasting at that time um
so acknowledging that it's it's it's it
will have that that look um of of
rusting but we do know that sheet piling
is quite a common um River protection
methodology and it it it probably will
look similar to that in fact the the
nzta the Waka kahi guys we spoke to both
the funding um side and the technical
side and they're very interested in
being kept informed about this uh it may
prove to be something that you know they
they they think about rolling out and
and like I said to to them you know
they've got a lot of rivers like this in
the canbury area and you know it may be
something that if it can be put in more
cheaply and stay longer and more
resilient that they're interested in So
you you're saying that you're expecting
sort of 20 to 30 years as opposed to you
know my estimate of 5 10 I'm not worried
about the visual look at the
of that because it is no different to
the so you you think it might last that
long yes we do thank you C
Williams um Council X and stole my
question then oh well you know anyway
that's good we we keep moving uh Council
of
Duty well we were actually same all on
the same page right but I've well I've
got to extra place
just yeah just um the question is that
when perhaps these containers get to a
level where they will become probably
dangerous how what would you be doing to
El to stop them from perhaps after a
severe flood like that going Downstream
and creating problems down
further so what what is your the
long-term plan of where do you move
to with thinking the most likely um
disruption to them will be potential
undermining and they'll they'll settle
or slump if they if a big flood causes
it we've spoken to uh the Ean River
engineer Ian Hislop uh who's who's
wanting to ensure that we get some depth
below the river level in order to uh you
know be closer down towards the scar
depth now he's putting the scar depth of
that River around about 2 m we're not
going to bury them to Me 2 m because
then we're not going to have too much uh
above the above the bed level and
defeats the purpose of we but but we
will be looking to bed them sort of 1 to
1 and 1/2 M which will leave 1 to 1 and
1/2 above the ground given these things
are 2.4 to 2.7 High um we're not
expecting because of the weight in them
because we' filled them with gravel
we're not expecting they will actually
move of their own valtion and also
because they we're wiring them together
we think they'll stay as as a lot but it
could well be that you know they get a
little bit uh out of alignment or uh up
and down and and the good thing about
these is we can pick them up and and
relevel the base and you know put them
back in place or replace them uh in in
the future if that is needed thank you
thank you can some meetings just in
addition to the questions that we've
just had around their possible longevity
and and maintenance and whatnot um I
knowe that you say that this is a high
amenity area and the Aesthetics might
not be terribly pleasing are we looking
to perhaps paint them I know that sounds
like a crazy thing but or or they just
going to be something you know a big red
container that says Hamburg suit on the
side just thrown into the you know
because I have a couple containers in my
place and um you know having having them
actually painted uh makes a difference
as far as the Aesthetics go and also my
afford some protection to rust and
whatnot depending on what is used on
them we did consider and talk about that
right from the start as as as Engineers
on on the ground wondered if painting
was a good method or a good approach
we've ended up not recommending or not
proceeding with that and I think there's
a couple of reasons one is we are trying
to work within a pretty tight budget at
the moment um and secondly I think it'll
be a little bit of a a monitor and see
and if these things if the gravel we
push up against these is washing out
every 6 months and these are exposed and
you know people are aware and and and
concerned about it then that is
something that could could come in uh
you know at that stage but at this stage
it's not part of our uh intended
maintenance
program yep uh further question did you
have here a question yeah just just giv
I know you Engineers love to to enough
to engineer things this sounds exciting
um the given the depth that we were just
talking about did you investigate
actually digging one into the ground
whing one to the top and putting another
one up you know taking the floors out
them did you go that far as to the
Heights or or and and you just came out
that this is adequate or if there was a
bit more budget is what I'm asking would
it be better to have one on top of the
other we are concerned about the visual
impact I think and would be the answer
to that we're purposely wanting them
sort of almost set low and when we were
standing there with uh you know our
experienced River engineer I had sort of
a a height and was talking about you
know that rock over there at the just
underneath the Sait of the bridge he was
saying no we would be lower than that so
we're certainly looking to only you know
let's just say as I say about a meter
above bed and then building so that will
become the foundation for our gabian and
whatever on top and that way for the
majority of the events that come down
they will be down below that uh event so
we will actually have that good solid
foundation for the majority of EV and uh
what I what it is in here but I I failed
to mention in my uh introduction is we
are also looking at uh putting in a a
planned overflow Point further Upstream
which will take flow away so these large
50 or 100 Year events will go a
different way before they actually
impact too much on the bridge okay uh
you're prepared to move Council Duty
seconded by second uh Council duty to
speak thank you very much for this this
was very interesting and just bringing
your last little part out about that
you're going to do an an
overflow further Upstream would makes me
feel a lot more comfortable about this
but um that's quite ingenious during
that thank you thank you um do speak
yeah look I think I think this is well
worth doing it I mean given the the
expected time and I mean you'll never
know that until such time as they
they're there but um given the expected
time it's a pretty costeffective way of
uh of of some flood management so we'll
sit here and and all hope like hell that
it uh that it does the job it's supposed
to do and well done for uh for going
outside the square and trying to get uh
get things done not only on budget but
um a bit differently to try something
else agree agree with that those
comments and look Val people are are
real people they as you know because
you've been dealing with them they will
um they'd rather have resilience there
uh and coming up with a f functional and
pragmatic idea that this is I think
they'd rather that than the wash outs
going all the time so I think this is an
excellent solution and I'm not concerned
if we get any negative feedback at the
end of the day with tring this so good
work really good work C meetings
I would also Echo that sentiment I think
it's a very clever U solution that
you've come up with and it'll be
interesting to see how it how it works
out hopefully it works because I mean at
this point you know we've got to throw
whatever we can at it and that what we
have been doing has been um washing out
time and time again so well done um I
would just note on 6.2 sustainability
and climate change impacts of your
report says that this has not have
sustainability or climate change impacts
and I'm afraid darling Dawn that it's
all about the sustainability and climate
change impacts as to this so just next
time when you write a report if you
could just kind of that would be good
things in defense of Don I know this was
a was really quickly put together so
thank you Don and I know that some of
the TS might have been missed but
perhaps Point noted yeah thank you all
right okay R reply Council Duty and list
is with the speak thank you darling Don
that's well done
yeah um M Mr Yang or da will do thank
you thank you
Team all right that's the right of reply
gone I'll put that all those in favor
please say I contr declare it carried
right moving along thank you all right
um we've done uh
8.1 so let's do 8.2 now uh Grant
is Grant Grant's playing with the door
in there I
thinking we
are assume that you're looking after the
maintenance of Po yeah yes thank you 140
to 150
team
this is the maintenance of Po at the
entrance of Pegasus Town um it is 8.2 so
you need to go back into your out of
the back into the back into the previous
right grant thank you thank you uh me
again without a mask with a tie very
smart carry on uh so um I'll take the
report mostly As uh read I guess um it's
kind of important to understand a couple
of things in terms of what this report
is looking to um I guess asked from the
council and achieve the PO that are
currently sitting at the front of the
pigasus township development are on
private land um they were gifted uh some
time ago to the I guess the people of
the district albeit not necessarily on
Council land
itself um staff have been uh for some
time now trying to
talk with uh local ranga plus also with
the master caras on the particular
project as well just to kind of see the
sorts of things that we would have to do
in terms of um I
guess bringing the PO back up to their
uh former glory generally with something
like that you would probably do
maintenance every eight or so years um
unfortunately these haven't really had
any maintenance since 2008 um when they
were when they were put in so it's kind
of looking to redress that there been a
lot of um communication from the public
and also from local elected members as
well around what it is that we could do
as a council to help um actually restore
these back to to what it was that they
were uh looking like hence the
conversations that staff have had with
um local Ranger and and the master
carers and also the pigasus um Golf
Course owners as well
um the report that's in front of you is
suggesting that it's going to cost us
around about 9 and a half 9 $9,600 to do
some of the uh remedial work to those
and then possibly about another $20,000
on top of that um should we require it
for the ongoing work that we're going to
be that we're going to be looking at for
that um look I'm I'm happy to take uh
questions on that and uh let you direct
the conversation from here thank you
questions councilor Williams councilor
Blacky yeah
um for the rang community board we have
a town entrance fund we use um on things
like that um has that gone towards the
wooden Pegasus community board CU
actually should be coming out I believe
in the town
entrance um fund that the community
boards get to spend
um is is that what your thoughts on
that so what's actually sort of stated
within the report under the financial
information is that we're kind of asking
for additional funding to to look at
doing this staff could certainly go away
and look at whether or not that fund
could extend to this um because yes
technically it is part of a a town
entrance way um I haven't spoken to the
wood andf and community board directly
on on doing that um in their particular
area but it's certainly something that
we could investigate as part of this
yeah and you said that's been donated to
the people of pxas who actually owns it
so it's been donated to the area um and
that's really important to remember this
was
so these were windfeld uh totra which
were um carved um outside of the region
for the region um that doesn't
necessarily mean that they actually
given to the region under public
ownership um hence why we're coming to
the council now to kind of uh ask this
question do you support us maintaining
them so the they're not the council
they're definely like Council land so
the land is pigasus golf course so
really that's the pegas golf course's
product that's a very complicated uh
question um well is it or is it
not it's it is very complicated in the
sense that was discussed that management
of Chris was here he'd be able to go
through that for you in the sense that
the Pegasus golf club and how it was
originally put together the owner no
longer there the current owner does not
see it as his responsibility and we've
got these po sitting there which are
beautiful uh deteriorating and it's
becoming a reputational issue for us
with uh local n to her area who are
disappointed at its condition so that's
why it's ended up here otherwise no one
will maintain so so the question is can
they be removed onto Council
property
there's there's quite a substantial
process to do that especially given the
significance of the artwork as well um I
don't believe that has been explored
because of the complexity of around that
Council
Bey yeah my one of my questions was very
similar to Paul's ownership and I I'll
bring that up further in debate in a
minute um the quote I'm I'm a bit
puzzled about this quote on page 146 it
says um quote includes BL and then you
go to the next page and it says it
doesn't include paint sealant thinners
and the UV protection product well
that's not a quote I mean that's like
selling a car and saying it doesn't
include the steering wheel and the the
filler cap and the windscreen wipers
that's a guest toate it's not a quote at
all and why why why can't we have a I'm
put another way I'm not comfortable um
make this a question is everybody
comfortable with um the fact that
they've given us a price and quite a
substantial amount of the materials
aren't included in the
price that that's a question for me um
yeah look we as staff we were
comfortable with the quote that we
received it's been
um it's been difficult to get some
genuine straight answers just around
this uh often with artwork of
um with artwork when you're dealing
directly with the artist who uh still
has the IP and a general interest in
actually maintaining an upkeeping um and
also any that has any cultural
sensitivities you're kind of directed
and driven by what the master Carver or
the artist um interpretation is in terms
of what it is that you've got to do it's
not necessarily as straightforward as
going to to a a sort of you know an
engineer or a consultant and saying
right can you quote me for this um so it
does come with some risk um certainly in
terms of in terms of that with art work
of this nature um and that's hence why
we've sort of added a little bit more in
there in terms of what's been asked for
of the
council okay further questions Council
Ward followed by redmund um if is this
owned by
um no who is it owned by they owned
by yeah uh and again that's that's kind
of the complexity around it because it's
it's been given to the district at the
time that somebody else who was a little
bit more philanthropic uh towards the
community took them on board um at that
point in time it was kind of the wow
factor of coming into the township of
Pegasus it kind of sorted that that
particular um sort of wow factor that
they were looking for uh a lot of the
time with art that's put in um
especially cultural art that's put in
there's often uh I guess a role for
Council to play there in terms of when
you get to this sort of situation um if
others aren't willing to look after it
it really does come down to that
reputational question um around what is
the right thing to do and hence why
we're here today because we can't just
go and maintain it um we actually need
approval to do so well um why why isn't
there a partner parip with um the people
that put it there and us to maintain it
why are they charging us a a full quote
to maintain it why aren't they doing
that voluntarily for us to help us we'll
pay we pay might need to pay for the the
ingredients but you know why can't they
culturally um do the job um as part of
their
culture in terms of uh I guess the fact
that this was a gift from the the people
of the land to the area um the master
Carver themselves isn't necessarily uh I
guess the Rona or representative of the
Rona they're still an independent artist
at the end of it and this is their uh
livelihood I guess as it would be for
any other contractor that we might
approach um that would be a truly uh
philanthropic approach that they would
have to take um and again not knowing
what the agreement was back in 2008 when
this was put on
generally you would work that out at the
time um between the council between the
local runger and if it wasn't going on
Council land you would want to make sure
that it was very clear as to who was
going to maintain it at that particular
point in time um the fact is a lot of
the time when there's assets that are
put into the community or into the
district which have uh I guess a wider
Community purpose we will as Council be
looked upon to help out and take
ownership of these issues when they
arise um which we don't always have uh
control over them happening um but
unfortunately we do have to uh I guess
address the conversation around whether
or not it's our responsibility Simon did
you want to
something my understanding is the the PO
were commissioned by pigasus Town
limited from
kakura uh ewi uh so they are not they
they are not something that is the local
e have a particular relationship with
just it's but but they do but they do
very strongly those of us remember of
Mahi tah know that they ask regularly
not to if they're going to be maintained
and looked after so from from that
perspective course they that they do
very strongly make um um state that they
want them looked after and maintain it's
really complicated team and from your
questions they're all questions that are
absolutely right but someone has to
ultimately uh take responsibility look
after them otherwise they're just going
to sit there and deteriorate um that's
that's and and that's the debate here
today so um I've got uh questions from
Council Redmond ainson and Williams if
we're just going around the same Circle
then we could just debate it I real
there's a lot of reports here today so
if you've got genuine questions go for
us but I just suggesting we might just
get to debate
shortly thank you Mr Mayor I take the
hunt and I'll be brief uh when I first
read this I thought it was
9,600 and you wanted budget of 20 am I
correct in thinking when I read it again
you're wanting a budget of
39,600 wow and secondly were the
Templeton group approach for a
contribution I haven't any conversations
with the templon group so I would have
to I would have to find that out
um reading the recommendations here it
actually says that it's noting the
quoted cost for the restoration was uh
9,600 but it's only the council's been
asked to approve additional budget
allocation of 20,000 for this
project so it's an additional 20,000
that's been asked
for closer of the
9,600
that's how I've read
it okay uh councelor uh
tinson I'm not sure whether I can ask
this question there and put it in the
debate but I'll I'll ask if don't want
to answer it now I'll debate it but I
just wonder whether um because ownership
has come up here Grant whether um
looking at the W Arts trust or the
Heritage um fund whether these because
they're in public ownership whether they
are two places in which the mate of
these could could fit I mean ultimately
funding would come from the same place
if you like but it would actually give
them a a home to sit under to give
maintenance to rather than just coming
here and having all of these questions
all of the time um and it may not be
that you answer that now it might be
that you know that's after this goes
either through or not that you look at
either one of those plac or some of
those places for that to go yeah I could
probably just make a a quick comment on
that um Council Atkinson and if you look
under um if there one of the things that
we'd really like to do is actually work
on a legal legal agreement to tidy all
of this up um and I think that that
would be the best place to kind of
explore some of that as well because it
would make sense that that would be one
of the options that would be
discussed okay uh thank you councelor
Williams considering the local renang um
turn said it's a good cultural um
scenario have they been asked if they
want to take ownership of um these and
maintain them
themselves they they have been they have
been approached um they would prefer
that any asset like this which is kind
of perceived to be public that it would
remain with the public entity which is
the council okay well but we've got a
recommendation here um well can you just
was going to suggest you add H to H
which is in the wooden sifton community
board that y just to because it should
go the community board I'm happy to
second that can well look just very
quickly I think you get the Guist of
where I'm going these are in public
ownership they are public they were
gifted from Kora um and um and they were
a gift to this community which uh
they're they're very cool um I actually
went to the um unveiling of them Sandra
you were there um in fact Mr M I think
you may have been there um and it it was
a pretty emotional unveiling to be quite
honest um for a bit of dirt to be quite
honest the people in this District
weren't that Keen on at the start which
was the whole of Pegasus um but it did
actually give it a bit of a meaning and
a bit of a uh uh a bit of a place to go
I we knew this question was always going
to come up because it was actually asked
around that time at the unveiling well
who are they what are they you know no
one actually had the answer just as our
staff and and those people dealing with
it have come up with now but I think we
could find not a place for them to go
but a place for the maintenance to go is
where I'm coming from they're in public
ownership which means that everybody's
it doesn't matter who who it is it is
theirs and and and I talk about the
group that L you know looks after um
with the Arts or the Heritage fund and I
talk about them quite deliberately
because if they are in our district plan
as a Heritage item then they're open to
some funding um from that Heritage fund
if they're in the Arts will the Arts
people can help um along with Council to
uh fund some further maintenance of them
instead of us having this this debate
which is the right one to have um but
instead of us having that we can
actually have uh they have some uh some
love and care coming from somewhere in
someone um to make sure that they're
very well preserved because believe me I
think they are magnificent and uh I
would hate to see them fall into too
much disrepair that's for
sure greate and highly with councilor
Atkinson's remarks they're beautiful um
they they're an entrance to a town yes
the ownership is a little confused um in
the sense of where they cited um
Templeton group actually have nothing to
do with the ownership of the entrance
it's actually um the golf club and
that's Sam Ho uh and his company uh I
don't know whether the conversation's
been had with Sam but it's a different
own than who originally put it in the my
understanding is that
um it it is viewed that it's the
council's responsibility and and
ultimately it does fall on us to find a
way look it is a reasonable sum of money
but it's uh and I think we just need to
get on before they further deteriorate
to relationship um with n to heri that
they have raised so in terms of our
relationship with n heri they
continually raise um who's looking after
them how are they being looked after so
it's time we need to get on with it yes
it's a reasonable sum of money but
otherwise they're going to sit there and
further deteriorate that could well cost
us further it's an entrance to our town
I think if makes it really clear and
agree with councilor Atkinson that we
need anou whether it's um the trust that
our was involved with um or whatever
body um but we do need to just sort this
once and for all so I support this
direction thank you further
speakers Council
meetings I just say
aside from you know who owns it I mean
it's it's a public it is
public art and it is a tonga it's
something that is quite precious and has
been entrusted to us and we shouldn't
just let it fall into disrepair while
we're standing around arguing whose side
of the fence it sits on so I support us
maintaining and up keeping it cancer
brings cancer
Williams you my biggest concern is we'd
actually don't own the land that they
sit on um the golf club's already been
sold once for all we know it could get
sold next week and they don't want them
there and um put a bulldozer through
them well we don't know that and um so
I'm not going to vote for spending
public money on something we don't own
and we don't own the land and we've got
no control over it okay right cancer
Dy thanks very much um I'll make sure
you grants with getting these um tidied
up and and then for the future maybe
under the um wayer Arts trust that
perhaps they look look at it about every
10 years just to see that they are still
in good condition um it's it's really
important to maintain these beautiful
pieces of Art and um they're sitting
there magnificently so they they do need
a a little bit of a face liift Okay C
redmund thank you Mr Mayor um just
following on from councilor Williams
would it be possible to get the
agreement referred to in F before we go
committing ourselves and spending money
on things that may have a limited life I
certainly think these are worth
preserving and they are magnificent and
do need to be renovated but if we could
have an agreement first I'd be more
comfortable with spending the
money
well that's a question and that's up to
staff it's not included in the
recommendation so that's uh something
you might want to think about gr y
i okay all right further speakers R
reply yeah look I I I think ownership is
very clear may not be on our land but
ownership is very clear they belong to
the public that's what they were donated
for of this District that's very very
clear in my mind
um don't dispute it for one second we
own we um maintain many things that we
don't own we Supply tractors to the odd
uh Sports ground for them to maintain
the sports ground we don't own the
ground Kaio Park is the perfect example
um we paint some buildings uh in for
places that we're uh we're in
partnership with what's the difference
here there isn't any difference we just
need to get on and do it and we need to
acknowledge
that they are in The District's Public
ownership the ground they sit on is
almost irrelevant and in my view it just
it doesn't
matter they public things sit on all
sorts of ground I mean just have a look
out the window there there are Ean Banks
sitting on we don't know whose land
because as long as I've been on this
Council and for hundred years before me
everybody's fought about whether Council
owns the ground that sits on or whether
it's whether it's um Ean or whether it's
doc or whether it's the government that
still owns it and we still don't know
but we fund it we put we mow the we wow
The
Lawns we put the pontoons in the river
who owns it we don't know but we do it
so I don't see any different here apart
from the fact that it is very very clear
that they are that those things were
donated as into public
ownership okay I'm going to put the
recommend ation all those in favor
please say I
contract so I declare that carried and
your against do you wish your vote
recorded So councelor Williams is
recording his vote right I actually
thought it was 3:30 um but I realized my
clock my watch is a bit slow so um I was
call us to stop at about 3:30 so we're a
little late so we're just going to have
a break for about 10 minutes or so and
come back and um look team can I just
we might just need to pick up the pace a
bit otherwise we'll be here till 9:00
with the um things we've
got thank
[Music]
you
he
[Music]
oh
o
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
he
yeah
[Music]
oh
let's get it back into some CS of order
um well it would
help it will be live streamed 10 all
right let's let's go into uh I'll wait
for Adrian okay
Adrian okay so we're at 8.3 now pages
151 to 198 so we've got vanisa and Simon
Vana thank you good afternoon councilors
and Mr M so the purpose of this report
is to approve the draft District parking
strategy for public consultation so
we're looking at a one-month public
consultation period from 18 October
through to 14 November uh we're hoping
to bring the final um District parking
strategy back to Council on 7 December
for final adoption and you'll note that
we're running that public consultation
period alongside the same time frame as
the um proposed District plan um
consultation uh and we've I've had a
word to comms about that and they don't
see that as being any um any problems
with that they feel the audience is
quite different for both um
consultations particularly for the
district parking one where it's quite
high level um we'll be primarily taring
targeting um specific interest groups in
the community although obviously the
general public can provide feedback um
we also think it's important to have the
adopted parking strategy completed by
the end of the year as you probably all
know the minimum parking requirements
are being removed from the operative
District plan in February next year so
we think it's quite handy to have the
adopted parking strategy in place which
outlines Council stance on parking going
forward if we get any questions sort of
after February in terms of how we're
going to respond to certain aspects um
so I'm happy to take to take any
questions but before I do I just want to
highlight light the 85% Benchmark that
we've got in one of the policies as the
parking Trigger or when a new control or
parking intervention is required um you
may recall with different parking
strategies that we've put forward or
parking surveys sorry I should say that
we've put forward um in the past they
outline 80 to 85% as the um optimal
parking o occupancy that is recommended
by transport Consultants um you'll know
there's probably some tension often in
the community where they would like to
see a much lower level so we at the
moment we're sort of sitting in the 60%
range for ruro and we often get feedback
there's not enough parking so I just
wanted to highlight that we've kept that
85% Benchmark because there are
implications if we reduce that to a
lower standard which has a fla and
effect of requiring um more parking
Supply or um uh you know more efficient
parking measures like smart parking as
you may or recall the rular Town Center
Parking strategy already had a
requirement for 800 Parks up to 2048 at
the 808 85% Benchmark so if we were to
allow that then obviously that would
increase that need for Supply
potentially going forward so I just
wanted to highlight that as a reason why
we kept it at the 85% threshold so happy
to take any
questions thank you um any questions
thanks V it's very good report good
summary so questions Council Williams
move right well um so Council Williams
is going to move seconded by Council
Blacky yes
you're nodding at the right time so coun
Williams no good report and it's out for
um consultation so thank you Council any
further speakers I'll put that all those
in favor please say I cont to clear it
Carri right you've called us at a good
time um see you later thanks Vanessa um
now 8.4 so we've got Lenley um can we
someone go and get Lenley and uh
Kelly yeah put your coat on be you want
PL I
hav I've got wo on so that's really
messy today um perhaps we could look at
the temperature in here because don't
want to have um too chilled out
counselors
maybe maybe we should
shift shift our air conditioning man
from 40 hour
[Laughter]
R okay we'll just wait for Adrian to pop
back welcome Lenley and uh Kelly thank
you so team we're on 8.4 which is Page
um
so Pages uh so it's 8.4 Pages 199 to
215 it's Northeast rang EUR Development
Area proposal so Linley and Kelly would
you like to speak thank you thank you Mr
R so this um report
is the recommendation from the hearings
panel on the SCP for the Northeast
rangor Development Area so this was a
series of roading projects to be
included within the Northeast rangor
Development Area and it seeks um to add
these projects to the budget um as
growth and levels of service projects so
the um hearing took place on the 15th of
September with the um hearings panel
recommending option one which is
adopting the budgets um and the
development contributions becoming
effective
immediately I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
questions do you want to add anything
l no okay oh um sorry before I put the
motion I'll be have someone move it so
I'm prepared to move uh maybe the
hearing panel members we shouldn't um so
perhaps others than um Council duties
prepared to move aren't you and seconded
by Council meetings excellent would you
like to speak to the motion that you're
so prepared
for very good report thank you other is
other is councel
mailings any further speakers councel
yeah I'd just like to um reinforce that
the um our staff communicate with the uh
developers and try to get the traffic um
alleviated from kenberg R developments
done the developer indicated his um
thoughts for that would been good um he
was we concerned with getting consent to
put a another road in the other area but
the side road from Golflinks um Road
there it fully form it if they just make
it sort of um so they get all their
tracks of movement and that would be
very um helpful for the community thank
you Council
Ward um yes I think this is um a very
good development I think it still has to
pass the minister um but I think that
the distribution and the commitment of
the developer and the and the staff are
well balanced and um it's very exciting
looking forward to to it thank you uh
councelor
redmund uh just just a question Mr Mia
were the submitters apart from one um
supportive of this
outcome this on the whole the they were
all in support um the one person that
wasn't was um she actually was against
any development whatsoever so it was out
of the the scope of our actual
consultation but we tabled her thoughts
um as we do with all these
things thank you and I just say I think
this is the easiest hearing process I've
ever ched uh because of the excellent
work that the staff had done in
preparing us and also um the developer
coming along um in support uh and they
were good submissions so it was a really
good process that have been put together
which makes it uh easy to support today
really in that respect because there's
um alignment so just to acknowledge the
staff for their work and getting us to
this point so thank you further speakers
Rod
reply do you wish to
speak
okay I I I take it as quite heartening
that there were
no responses received against the
proposal and that it shows that we are
hopefully heading in the right direction
and it goes a long way into um
liberating a bit of land for some more
housing which we desperately need and
also fulfilling our obligations in the
greater Christ Church partnership so
cool well done thank you
question the um espad Reserve or strip
uh along the cam there can you just
refresh my mind about what um what
distance back from the river is
proposed um I believe believe it is 20
m is that up to the spring heads I don't
know the extent of it off the top of my
head so perhaps um if if you're okay
with this Kelly maybe just an email back
to councelor Stewart to advise good
thank
you right I'll R reply Council Duty I'll
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say I contr declare that
carried thank you team um we're now at 8
point 5 which is the reconsideration of
three Waters rating structure 216 to
236 three Waters gosh that's so unusual
we talk about three Waters
wow hi Simon Kelly good to see you both
cheers um so um this report follows on
from a working party that was set up in
2017 um
under the previous Council that
considered a three Waters review um the
original program had a 2021 start on
reconsidering the issue um but this
report in front of you proposes delaying
a relook at that issue until the outcome
of the government three Wars Review is
known um the original review uh was was
triggered from rat challenges that
existed at the time um some of those
have uh been overcome more recently with
stimulus shov ready funding uh but the
underlying issue of the affordability of
rates for improvements the small rural
scheme Still
Remains um since the original work was
carried out the question of whether to
consider stock water and a wider rural
drainage view in any rates review has
been raised so that's been included as
an option in this
report um a possible program to continue
looking at the issue based on three wers
of Reform Clarity by March 22 is
included Ed uh but the report notes that
if a decision or if decisions about the
three Waters reform have not been made
by March 2022 there will not be adequate
time to consider three Waters rating
reform in time for implementation for
the 24 to 34 ltp so the sort of T the
clock's ticking at this point in
time okay any questions thank you did
you want to anything Kelly questions
coun um if in fact we're not going to
look at this again till well the delay
till March 2022 if we wanted and then as
you've just indicated that flips it out
another 2 3 years um can you tell me
what would be the time frame if we
wanted to actually um consider it
independently of three Waters
potentially um or get it into either
well an an manual plan as a consultation
item the next one like this one coming
up 22
23 so are you talking about um rural
drainage and stock water or all the
whole lot well the whole lot but
certainly um I think we have a real
problem with some with uh rural drainage
um uh rating and um well more than just
rural drainage but certainly that and um
the issues that were have been
interestingly brought up some of the
issues that were bought up this morning
through the property
um uh acquisition and Disposal um
considerations so when could we I mean I
think we have to I think you've asked
your question thank you I'm glad I hear
you
yes it's it's about an 18 month or
minimum of an 18mon lead time in front
of the next
ltp um which is why that March 22 days
is a bit of a drop dead
date a question to the chief executive
um is around just if if there was to be
take on board councilor Stewart's
questions what's the staff capacity to
undertake reviews either
concurrently at the present time uh just
appreciate an answer that all from
Jared's perspective thank you sorry I
didn't see you there Jared even though
you were there uh look that's okay
um really stretched um just to give you
an idea I think we've lost four senior
engineers in the last few months um and
we're in a really difficult recruitment
environment so uh um we're actually uh
contemplating coming to you next month
um with a report to talk about our whole
work program for the year um
so uh the capacity is very minimal at
the moment and um any additional
workload for us will cause issues in
other areas um we realistically we'll be
coming to you and saying um some of the
things that we' promised to do this year
um we'll be recommending that we look at
other options for
that thank you uh further question
questions got a recommendation some
prepared to move you move councel
Williams seconded Council
Edmund uh would you like to
speak no it just makes um a bit of sense
to put this off until we know exactly
what's happening with what the
government's um dictating to us
councelor
Edmond yes I concur with what councilor
Williams said and I think it would be
confusing for the public if we go out
and consult on three Waters at a time
when depending on the minister um there
may or may not be
consultation uh regarding the reform
program so I think it's wise to put it
on hold can
J um I understand what everybody staff
is saying here but I can't support this
I think um having dealt particularly
with the rural drainage issues we are
virtually negligent as a council in
dealing with um a mish mash of rating
systems that we've inherited since
amalgamation and um we we have a pop
Mark piece of um rating area uh makes no
sense um the
2017 excellent um inhouse group that
Simon put a hell of a lot of work into I
thought was coming back well 2021 and um
it should have been in front of us um in
2019 just to actually scope out what we
were going to do and now we presented it
like this and in fact what we're saying
because of an external reform exercise
which I I don't demean uh well I don't
discount at all you can't but in fact we
have got numerous issues that I think
are um on the rating and supply of
service that our um rate payers and
residents are going to be far worse off
by flopping it out um and letting it
perhaps or not go into the fre Waters
reform and let some
external distanced Authority deal with
rather than actually starting the the
exercise now inhouse and I understand
what you're saying about um capacity and
I would like to see um uh some options
put to us because we are going to leave
many of our rate payers high and dry
here um high and dry
yes um well maybe maybe but certainly I
can't support putting it out effectively
what you're saying here is because we
can't do it it has an 18mon lead in
it'll flip out until a until a um um the
next ltp when we may have no actual
influence on how we um how we we
redesign our rating system at all and I
don't think that sits poorly with me and
I think it would be absolute disservice
to our rate payers so I can't support
this and I would actually urge um the
council to give thought about how you
can start to advance some of these
really unpalatable rating issues that um
we need to we need to address we're
we're letting our rate pairs down by
flipping it out again thank you thank
you C reinson
yeah look I I don't agree with that that
we're letting our rate payers down by
doing what we're doing I think the way
we'd be letting our rate payers down
would be going out to double consult on
something that we've consult well that
they're listening to and that we're
dealing with to death it's just about
killed all of us but we seem to be on
the brink of the cliff
um we um we need to make sure that
people actually understand what we're
talking about and it may be done to us
we don't know yet but by February it may
be done to us and the rating system that
we're looking at may be a very different
Beast for three Waters than uh then we
can get anywhere near I don't want to go
out and come to some conclusion that
we'll change things and then the
government come back to us a few months
later and say actually won't make any
difference just wipe that out because
here it is this is what it is we've also
on top of that got local government
reform and what comes out of local
government reform by way of waiting and
and um and uh funding we won't know so
we're right in the middle of those
actions to throw another one on top of
our rate PS I think would be absolutely
irresponsible of us to
do I totally concur uh with those
comments uh and from the question to
jured the real concern for me is just
our capacity of Staff um to undertake us
we've already put enough pressure on
them with helping us with the three
Waters response and they've done
magnificent job as we discussed last
week that's put huge pressure on our
organization and as you've heard we've
lost four which is actually a direct
consequence um of the reform proposal in
any event where uh staff are starting to
be poached uh and that's not just with
our organization with others so it's a
very real issue I sympathize with
councelor Stewart's perspective I would
like to see us undertake this but at a
time when we have some clear space
hopefully to get this done right right
uh but at the moment going out is just
not the right time and uh we will just
need to see where we get to where're
going to a Lobby and argue as hard as we
can to keep our three Waters here uh as
we resolved last week uh in our um
proposal to government and we we don't
know where the nature is going to be I
heard on um News Talk ZB today there are
less than six sorry there's six councils
that have opted in out of the 67 I don't
don't know who they are it was reported
by Mike gardley on there I don't I
haven't been able to verify that for
myself but that's what he staged on
there so it's a fairly it's a pretty
compelling case at the moment that
hopefully the the government will listen
to but there's so much uncertainty the
moment undertaking this is not the right
time he answer the meanings it's for the
sake of clarity and the recommendations
under e uh so that's not my
understanding is not withstanding us
putting a consultation off until there's
more clarity in the three Waters area It
also says that an opportunity exists to
proceed with considering rating
structure changes for stock water and
rural land drainage activities
regardless of whether the three Waters
um reform proceeds um so what would that
look
like um if we just looked at those
areas um stock Hort would be fairly
straightforward because that's not
affected by the three Waters reform but
um if that included rural drainage there
there's um my understanding is a lack of
clarity at the moment about what's what
may be included if the government pushes
ahead with uh the the three Waters
reform and its current um current form
about just exactly what's included so
there would um there would be some risks
in proceeding to look at uh stock water
and including rural drainage until we've
got clarity about
that okay further speakers couny yeah um
like you Mr M I have some sympathy for
for Council Stewart's comments about um
the anomalies in the system and they are
many but it at the end of the day it
goes back to item C in the
recommendation I mean that is the bottom
line and if anyone thinks that that
isn't isn't important we in the last 90
seconds we've just had an email come in
giving us another webinar on the
changing face of water regulations oh
what a
surprise few the
speakers um WR reply I can't remember we
moved it now um n sorry sorry I normally
write it down I didn't sorry councilor
Williams pardon me
yeah pardon me I'm
sorry um I'll put the recommendation all
those in favor please say I Contra
no thank you I declare it carried with
councelor um Stewart's vote recorded
against thank you Simon thank you Kelly
um so we now have 8.6 which is the uh
storage upgrade solution for manval
Headwater Sean forth's name here is sea
joining
us no he was here but he had to about
2:00 but that's okay it's undermining
Shan's
name hold on hold hold a sec
hold yes it's page
237 page
237 to 244 it's just got a miss
alignment with the tabs it is in
there yeah here we are sorry Colin we're
we're with you there we are page two
it's actually 243 of the agenda um 243
all right col right thank you you're
stepping in standing in for Sean y um so
the purpose of this report is to inform
the Council of an increase in the cost
estimate for the storage upgrade at
mandville um to advise that there is
another option of of changing the
storage tank type that we had looked at
but we recommend allocating the
additional budget in order to complete
the stainless steel option that we'
looked at um so I'll just talk through
quickly um how the cost increase has
occurred and how we've and the
reassessment we've done to come to the
conclusion so a b we currently have a
budget of
$510,000 for this project
um and through some more detailed work
we've identified we need another 350,000
which is obviously quite a significant
difference um so we did quite a bit of
work to
investigate why the change and we had
reviewed the costs for the Civil Works
of the project recently and were can't
confident in them but the one thing we
hadn't updated yet was the actual tank
itself because there's a large part of
the project as foundations and pip workk
and that kind of thing which we're
familiar with but the actual procurement
of the tank we have we haven't done a
stainless steel tank before and we' used
a figure from uh
201718 for a steel water storage tank
that we had from a consultant but
um what we've found is that this is in
terms of public water supply still a
reasonably new technology and certainly
in 2017 and 18 it probably wasn't
understood that well by the industry so
people had been um selling tanks with
the direct tank cost of around
$100,000 but um the in terms of the it
wasn't up to standard in terms of the
design criteria structurally in terms of
earthquake resilience or water tightness
so I understand um from our consultant
that there have been a few lessons
learned in terms of tanks that haven't
stood up to certain events or haven't
haven't proven to be
watertight um and so the the
understanding of what is required is a
lot better now in terms of Designing
them to the normal importance level um
criteria that you would for a concrete
tank or other tanks and also um in terms
of the industry realizing the the um the
requirements in terms of water tightness
too which also hadn't been
up to scratch with the early generation
tank so that took the direct cost of the
tank um up by whole order of magnitude
which should in turn affected the
overall project budget um so because of
the change we did go back to the
original multi criteria analysis that
was done and looked at other options
that were looked at then to see if it
would change things so we Revisited the
plastic tank option that was one of the
Alternatives and that would have in
instead of one single um welded
stainless steel tank we could have had
14 plastic tanks or
interconnected um there were and this
would be the estimate for this is about
the same as the budget we've got now um
but in doing this they would we would
take on a number of additional risks in
terms of the complexity of all the PIP
workk in and out of these tanks um and
each each tank has a hatch each hatch is
a risk they have events they've got
overflows they've got pip workk going in
and out and every point is introduced
some level of risk and for a small
number of Tanks you can manage that but
the more you get you get compounding
risks that
becomes less and less acceptable in the
current environment um and we also
talked to some of our neighbors so we
know that uh per we have recently
constructed a steel tank and also have
got some tank Farms like the alternative
that we looked at um and they'd given
some feedback about some of the
operational challenges with their
plastic tank farms in terms of getting
avoiding having water that's sits too
long and loses its chlorine or um short
circuits it and um doesn't get the
contact time
required um and we also talked to crush
city council through our drinking water
reference group who' looked at a
multicriteria analysis not down to the
scale of plastic tanks but between steel
and what type of Steel and concrete and
other um other are larger tanks and
they'd come up with stainless steel as
their recommended option and their cost
estimates are more in line with what
we're um proposing here um So based on
all of that we are still confident that
we got the type of
tank right um we just didn't get the
cost right in the first place or didn't
understand the requirements to build a
stainless steel tank to um to the
standard required so we are um confident
in the what the product needs to be um
and we now with the updated recommended
budget are confident in the cost as well
following the recent work so I'm happy
to take any questions on that thank you
questions Council
Duty thank you Colin just um just asking
um about the stainless steel tank for
looking to perhaps in case we have
another
seismic issue how are you going to sort
of um strap that down to make sure it
doesn't move they're usually um built on
a concrete pad so the concrete pad will
be fixed to the ground much like a house
or other building and the the steel is
fixed to the concrete so um there in
terms of uh size that's one of the
learnings um not I didn't have it
specifically talked about fixing it to
the ground but in general the importance
level three means it can withstand an
event of the scale and there's four
levels so three is normal for
infrastructure like this four is the
absolute top level that might be tank
that supplies a city like you know a
very large city but um this would
withstand um the type of events we've
had and is is consistent with the same
level that a concrete tanks are designed
to and my other question there is will
you still be holding one or two of those
Farm plastic tanks is a b up and yeah so
the idea was to to keep um couple on
site and they would be in case we need
to take the tank offline completely we
could use them for tank cleaning or for
yeah if if there was
a like some kind of event would that
took out the steel but not the plastic
but it would it would be more likely to
be the other way around that the steel
would survive and the plastic not well I
was just s of thinking perhaps with the
cleaning and something yeah cleaning
definitely that's that's the key reason
okay thank you the questions we have a
series of recommendations moved by count
stward just sorry do you want a
question okay I'll let councelor
meetings move seconded by councelor Will
Williams sorry you both had you hearing
that at the same
time
canings um thank you Colin for a very
in-depth report on this I know that
whenever you weigh up issues and options
that you've done your homework because
you're you've always been quite thorough
with these sort of things so um I put
confidence in what you've put in this
report um given that the area
in that is going to be served by this is
a growing area it's in need of
um better provision of infrastructure
and this is probably I mean this is the
best option that we can give them and
also for the fact that it is an area
that can experience turbidity in the
water and I like the you know whether
that's um due to um High rainfall or
seismic events or whatever um it it
gives me confidence that we can actually
also benefit if we go with the stainless
steel welded option that we can use the
pl old plastic tanks for a flush toist
system which you know is just a good
added extra because we'll be needing
that um looking at the Alternatives of a
plastic tank farm that's 14 different
tanks on the site which in addition to
being terribly ugly I would I would um
suggest also has you know 14 different
points of failure possibilities so I
think from a maintenance point of view
as well as aesthetically and just gold
standard going forward for 50 years plus
that this option is um likely to be able
to withstand for I think that this is a
a very good option it's disappointing
that the the cost um has escalated in
the last few years since it was it was
costed at but I still think that it
remains our best option and I hope
you'll support it thank you cancer
Williams I concur there the um the cost
is the only thing that's um a bit scary
but um we've all been talking about
three Waters and we've got on our brain
now we've been told we've got to lift
our game um this is lifting our game to
the best of the lot I would hate to go
and put in 14 plastic tents and next
thing you know the regulator turns
around say Well they're not going to
comply
because they can be a bit ify so um this
is by far the the best thing and um yes
I
thanks the speakers councel
Jewish I was wasn't going to ask this
question because it's a bit tangental
but the water services bill is now an
act um as of last week is there anything
in it that would impact on this or any
of other of our forward program uh it
will um
the main thing I think is it gives the
um tomato otherwi the ability to consult
on you drinking water standards which
they've been writing for the last year
and this this gives them the powers to
consult on them so they'll consult on
the standards and it will be the
standards that give us a whole bunch of
new obligations and I understand one of
the things in the standards is for each
Supply to have a reservoir management
plan so it's going to be a lot easier to
write that plan with a nice new
stainless steel tank than with a 14
plastic tanks for example so there is
some link with that as well as having to
meet good you know cine residual which
is more challenging with the the very
large tank farm options as well so
there's it all is tied
together okay further speakers no right
of reply Council
meetings look the stainless steel option
gives us greater resilience better
operational performance longer asset
life lower maintenance requirements
what's not to
like oh yeah there's that but then again
you know that in all likelihood that's
going to pay for itself over the time
and this is an asset that will last
longer than the other things that we
were looking at therefore I think in the
long term it'll actually come out
neutral I'll put the recommendation all
in favor please say I contrary declare
that carry thanks Colin now we're at 8.7
251 to 289
G
gcp yes I think you've been briefed on
this but basically the proposal here is
that the great of Christ Church
partnership committee continues and it
deals with nonurban growth sort of
strategic matters so what is now in
place will continue but there'll be a
new committee with essentially the same
membership with the addition of two
Crown ministers and we met with woods
and mutter at the sort of discussion
behind the last time um and if you look
at paragraph 4.4 page
254 this Urban growth partnership is
where the crown wants to engage more
fully with us around Urban Development
and future issues linked to it um
specifically that we're looking for a
well functioning and sustainable Urban
environment and the initial priorities
around decarbonizing the transport
system increasing resilience to Natural
hazards climate change uh accelerating
provision of quality affordable housing
and finally access to employment
education and services although on that
last one those two ministers made it
clear they weren't seeing Economic
Development as being progressed through
this new committee which was a surprise
to the rest of us and they're quite
adamant about it because they were
challenged so that's still sitting in
there um that's what we are asking you
to sign up to today so we'll leave it
there and deal with the politics later
um so the first cab off the rank in
terms of joint projects here is a
spatial plan which covers greater
chiste and that spatial plan will form
the bones of a future Canterbury spatial
plan once that's required through the
RMA reforms um so the proposal today is
to essentially um you know for you to
give Authority for us to sign up to that
through the mirr and delegate
responsibility to the mayor on 8.7 D not
the mayor and chair because obviously
that was written for the chair of the uh
Regional Council as well as the Mayors
um the membership here is unaltered so
that's the the mayor and councilor's
meetings and ainson will continue um and
I think in efficiencies they'll meet
with one hat on and then put another hat
on and ministers or the substitutes will
arrive and I think they're talking about
four meetings a year to to keep that
work agenda going so so this has been
enacted and this is what's happening in
places like the Bay of Plenty in Oakland
and Wellington so they do recognize
Christ Church is a significant player
and they want to see that alignment with
us through this
process thank thanks Jim uh any
questions uh some are prepared to move
just crossing out the cheer and
D moved councilor ainson seconded by
second it um do you wish to
speak has to be done in um I'm looking
forward to uh working directly with the
ministers um I'm not sure that one of
those ministers will be particularly
happy with us at the moment but uh that
will be uh this is a different subject
so um uh looking forward to because I do
know particularly in Tonga how they've
moved uh forward on the on their spatial
plans and things um they have some other
issues aside from that but uh with their
planning um and done it well by having
the the government ministers and
involved in what they do and um as Jim
says we'll just be changing hats while
we're there we're there anyway um I
remember Jim Palmer describing us as
having 40 businesses so this will just
be Hat number 41 and we'll carry
on uh support it as well it's look this
is really important we've we've we've
discussed it and and briefing it takes
us to the next level in terms of
influence having two ministers there and
one of them I hope makes greater note of
other measures that are important to all
of us it's no different to how we
operated some years ago with the um
recovery plan um and how the gcp sort of
um web development strategies that then
was sort of just flexed from time to
time and this is just to enable
ministers um participation so other
councils that have had this have have
really valued as Jims observed and I
think for us um if we can get some some
some change changes from government and
investment that out of this partnership
then it's that frankly where we need to
be heading so it's definitely heading in
the right direction so I commend it to
you all who the speakers uh Council of
meetings think this is a great step
forward for us it's an opportunity to
actually sit at the table with with the
the big players which dare I say it I
mean we are the second largest
metropolitan area in the country and we
haven't had that seat at the table which
you know begs a few questions so this is
really a fantastic opportunity for us to
actually get a chance to make our case
be known um on a bit more regular basis
and hopefully get some Traction in areas
that we are hoping to work together to
resolve so it's a positive thing thank
you further speakers I reply I'll put
the recommendation all in favor see
please say I contrary to clear it
carried 8.8 2022 council meeting
schedule s 290 to
294 thank
you good
afternoon so we have based um this
timetable for next year through to early
October based on the previous
timetabling with Tuesdays being the main
business day of council it's a very
similar uh pattern however as with each
year we've tried to anticipate the
demand such as
this year we've uh seen the increase in
UNR committees and a little bit less of
dpnr going forward as well as the
district plan rolls
through we've uh managed this year to
weav in two meeting weeks of uh a break
for counselors and for next year we're
proposing four weeks uh scattered
through which will hopefully help uh
workflows and Recovery now that's
excluding meeting times but it doesn't
necessarily um exclude your other
commitments that you have with the
community um there has been a suggestion
by Council Barnet that we look at um
amending the recommended audit and riff
committee time of 9:00 a.m. uh to 10:00
a.m. and I've been in discussion with
the manager of business and finance and
and there are times when we actually do
require that 3-hour time frame for audit
um particularly when we have presenters
from either ccos or
the um Treasury office so we're um
entirely in your hands but for
consideration that we remain at 9:00
a.m. start for audit and risk on the
days that we do have a present to
coming and on the days that that is not
scheduled to occur which is uh probably
three out of the six meetings that will
occur next near year um that they do
start at 10:00
a.m. um so we ask for that
consideration um if we were to swap the
timings for audit into the afternoon it
actually has an impact on the afternoon
schedules because the morning session is
a 3-hour meeting slot the afternoon is
actually a 5H hour slot of meeting times
and we would have to go back to the
drawing board um we do try to balance
everybody's other commitments that we
know about and also cluster the
particular counselors on committees so
that you're not backwards and forwards
with meetings and trying to make the
most efficient use of your time in
minimum time between meetings
um of waiting as well so I leave the
matter for your decision or questions
thanks S I just wonder with noting
Council Barnett's
request just as a suggestion maybe that
we change the commencement time at 10 on
Tuesdays but Ed uh note that the start
time may change in consultation with the
cheer maybe just as a suggestion that
may be a way of um overcoming uh the
matter so if there are be a flexibility
arrangement with the chair of the
committee which happens in any
consultation generally anyway around
business and those methods so if it
brought it forward but it sees the
commitment at te rather than trying to
be I don't know how we'd word it with
three this way and three that three at
three at nine and three at 10 but just
thought that might be a way of
overcoming that um we do generally know
the timings of when those presentations
are going to occur with the CC's
reporting or treasury we've also looked
back on the timetable and we do need the
3 hours definitely when they do
occur um usually
March May and perhaps August um I'd have
to reconfirm those times that they they
do come um we also require consistency
for the public to be aware and our
meeting advertising time
is some 3 weeks before these meetings
occur so for the actual planning and the
LMA requirements in the background we
actually do um advertise a lot earlier
than the meetings so if we're doing
additional meeting changes and things
that it does incure additional cost so
do we need to specify now what the times
of the meeting or do we just allow that
to flex no I suggest that we allow it to
flex and we utilize so so what time
would we what would your suggestion be
of wooding around the around
ey so commencing
it we can be specific on the dates that
um those ccos are coming yeah
I so why don't we just add that in 15th
of February and just put the dates the
times and the year cuz you
know it's 9 or does does anyone have any
objection with that must we can we can
we pass these with those dates to be
adjusted on the recommendation well as
opposed to because just in case one of
them's not the date we're thinking of
that's all well that's why I was
suggesting before it at at it 10:00 a.m.
on Tuesdays but note the start time
might may change in consultation with
the chair or I have a I have a question
in there and that is that a lot of us
have meetings with staff before we go
and or after if it's not a fixed time
it's very difficult to right get
staff I would rather use 9:00 a.m. as
the base Y and then as the agenda is
forming and we know the program of
presenters coming or not then we can
actually shorten that time and move it
forward I think we just record it in
debate the start time is 9: but we just
note and debate that's the easiest way I
think rather than going through now if
we knew exact oh I just don't want to
see you locked in too much that's why I
was trying to I understand and there may
be times when it is proposed that the
ccos are reporting in a particular month
but some things such as Lockdown occurs
and U other other circumstances move
there any
questions Council redmund just a
question per um would you agree that
9:00 a.m. would be theault provision
yeah and just your suggestion yeah well
I think I'll just leave it at 9: and
I'll I might just speak to that so it's
recorded in the in the debate that
covers that all right so I'm going to
move the recommendation as is some repat
the second happy just just to say look
sah thank you for the work that you and
your team do putting all this together I
know you're acting like a magician most
of the time trying to blend all our
Diaries and commitments that we we've
got work commitments and note that you
know there important that we possible
where there is work commitments that we
do try to be flexible but council is
scheduled as a Tuesday um so we do know
that every Tuesday we have got something
on except for the dates that you've
mentioned and thank you for factoring in
some break times I do think that's
important that there is in an
opportunity for members to plan um to
take some leave if they wish um so thank
you for factoring that in now the
councils do have started the practice of
doing that and I think it's healthy that
that is done and considered so thank you
around udit and risk I agree with your
recommendation that the base is nine but
where possible that those times are
shifted to 10 10:00 start time when
there's non um heavy report uh heavy
presentation so I think that's a very
fair compromise there so thank you uh
but apart from that thanks for all the
work that's gone into it which has been
extensive so thank
you thanks
yeah I'm happy with that I I think that
um uh the fact that we do on Tuesday
most of us impose on staff to have some
meetings with them before we go to
council because as you rightly point out
that uh Tuesday's Council day and um uh
before or after is Handy but more from I
would imagine a staff's point of view
it's pretty important that they know
that on certainly DLC is a good example
8:30 I meet um on a Tuesday Morning um
it may only be for half an hour
sometimes it goes a lot longer than that
you know but um on audit day it it
becomes a bit hard to actually uh to
actually have that meeting so I don't
really care whether we're 9 or 10:00 I
just think it needs to be stated and and
permanent so if it's three and three for
me that's that's great um because then I
can organize with staff what it is I
need to do before that or as I say I
don't mind which end it does or after
that whichever way it may be but I think
I think I'm trying to accommodate
councilor bu it is absolutely worthwhile
I mean I have my own work commitments on
other times um and I think that trying
to accommodate people around this table
is actually important we are part-time
counselors even though um sometimes it
certainly doesn't seem like
that c
Williams no I think good report thank
you in good um times and what have you
um with the order and rest when I do
believe we probably should all start at
the um the same time all the time cuz I
must admit I've gone to a meeting and oh
Cy was 7:00 one night all of a sudden
it's um well sorry the other way around
7:30 and I've turned up at um late of
the meeting because I've brought the
time forward at half an hour something
like that so I think it's important for
us in the public because the public need
to know consistency of their Council for
times going to meetings all drama so um
we all know Tuesday is full Council day
and I've also been to meetings and we
haven't finished before the next
committee starting and I actually
personally like a break between them so
I can sit and have a chat to colleagues
or go and have a drink and what have you
and I think that's important we don't
burn ourselves out by sitting in a
meeting all day with without no breaks
and and some days we we do sit there
with no breaks so you know I'd hate to
overlap meetings and um what we have
done
previously thank you further speakers
counil meetings question um you've got
those break weeks scheduled in are those
set in stone because I was just
comparing those with the school holidays
and one of them matches up the others
don't
when I cross referenced the school
holidays we did factor that in um I
think one was the first week of school
holidays we
certainly around Easter um through April
and then one of the other school
holidays is also factored in later yeah
it I think two two sets of school
holidays affected and two
other um break weeks and not affected
with school holidays yeah I I see that
one of them definitely does but the
other three three fall just
outside but that's all right it's hard
to it's yeah you can't be all things to
all people I just thought I'd ask the
question consider take
it
yeah thank you um any other
questions speakers nothing really to
respond to so I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say I contrary to clear that carried
thank you s um so no measures ref from
committee's German 10.1 is your report
health and safety 295 to 305 the report
is self-explanatory just for your
information we're looking at how we
actually report on our health and safety
performance and the risks that we have
so we're going through that process and
we're also just having a look at our
front counter staff to make sure that
we're doing everything we can to ensure
their safety because we're finding that
there's a few people who thanks to Co
and other things are a little bit more
aggressive than normal and we want to
make sure that we don't have an incident
where we can't support our people so um
we're just looking into that okay thank
you any questions of
Jim uh I'll move the recommend sorry El
do you want to move no you move it yeah
yep you move um Jan's going to Second at
you Joan so excellent any
discussion short and safety all those
favor please say I contr declare it
carried um Community boards um for
information well it's just saying that
due to lockdown they hasn't there aren't
board um minutes there has been actually
engagement with the boards because
there's been a formal meetings so then
we have reports for
information um Council Williams is going
to move 13.1 and 13.2 have been received
for information seconded by councelor
Blacky do you want to speak to that
councelor Williams I'll put that all
those in favor please say I contrary
declare that carried um there's no
correspondence my Diaries page 370 to
372 someone going to move that moveed
Council Duty seconded Council award um
any discussion I put
that all those in favor please say I
contary declare that carried in the
interest of time I'm just going to hold
off the portfolio updates to the end of
the meeting Sandra I know you're wanting
to leave it five so do you want a couple
of minutes on your one now because you
may not get a chance to do it later
great nothing much to add uh waiting I
think there was a reference last uh last
month about the uh e can report on the
lack of success on after 10 years of the
Canterbury Water Management strategy and
that was going to be referred to policy
for a report to us about what and
wherefor uh I'm waiting yeah I I welcome
that um because um I think it's um it
it's um well extremely sad that we can't
um after 10 years of the strategy uh
latch on to anything that's been
achieved at all around the Zone table um
Ean has changed the criteria of um the
immediate steps which is the only
funding that the um uh Zone committee
had to allocate to a 50,000 in the first
year which is the current year um no
criteria um yet and my colleagues around
the table are going around in circles
about how are we're going to evaluate
um uh projects uh if we're going to get
assign the money within this current
year of which we're um you know um 3
months into so I'll update you on that
and that's about it
thank you I might as well just might as
well just carry on because as e
relationships there's not much to to um
report on aart from I was very pleased
with the uh if you look on the district
plan the lovely words that Tamar um put
in there which I thought were um a real
was really nice to have that reflection
on our Council on the progress we've
made uh and um over the last number of
years and talking about obviously the
work all the work that have gone into
District plan review on the flip side of
that little disappoint well not just a
little disappointed um quite annoyed
quite frankly um with the article on the
Press on Saturday um I have um set up a
meeting for uh Friday where I'll have a
discussion around the reflections of our
work in um to a HEI which were not
accurately reflected uh I'm not going to
get into media discussion about that
matter or response or have a private
chat um about that matter so um I'm
going to do that on Friday afternoon um
I got nothing else to update onet space
any questions of me uh greater crich
partnership update I think Jim's really
it's been covered off just before there
is a spatial plan timeline that's going
on um you know some of us would really
like to see that done sooner rather than
later but it's the
discussion that we were having earlier
about Jared's team and that there's just
capacity in finding people that can
actually do it and burnout so we've just
got to be pretty real about it so um I
know we're all ambitious in that space
But that's just something we've got to
factor and there's just not enough
planners uh or people of that capability
to to assist and that's just a reality
of where things at they're all being
poached going into MF and other bodies
and so and other adverts for other
organizations at the moment so yeah but
the partnership's in good space so we've
got a meeting on Friday there's not much
else to add and Le ccel concern or
meetings when anything
no okay International relationships n uh
passion was taking along I was just
thinking about it yesterday actually
when I was reading this I think it's
time um we circulated some minutes from
the uh from the meeting we've had uh
around passionale just to bring you all
up to date there's some things in there
that are happening there some metals
that uh uh belong to uh uh C and D
company in Cross that uh are being
demolished in the liquidation of a
building and hopefully they're um going
to come out to uh well originally they
were going to the rangu RSA to go under
the under the fountain that they have um
but it would appear that um uh two of
them were were C company which is Kyo
and two of them for rura so um I sort of
stepped back from the table when Neil
and Ian started to uh discuss that
otherwise we might have had swords drawn
at um at dawn um so there may be two
coming this way to C and two going the
other way um that's for them to to work
out um and uh and also in that there is
um 11 pillars in the front of the
building um of which I was not aware of
that uh had significance and um we're
going to uh approach them um as the P
passo advisor group to uh try and get
them out here and we may be able to if
it all works out Grant close your ears
because I haven't even spoken to you
about this yet um but we're um uh there
may be something that we can put along
the passionale walkway that have uh some
for of sculptural um significance but
again we need to talk to the re to the
Liquidator of of who owns the building
to be able to do that um but that would
be kind of cool you could imagine like
four could very easily go at um at fide
Road entrances you know either side of
the road to bring you into the into the
walkway don't know haven't even really
got any further than than a thought yet
and whether we can get them or not
because if we don't the bulldozer will
just go straight through them is what's
happening so uh it's the um Crush yeah
crushit um Club RSA
yeah yeah so it's in liquidation is what
it is so they're moving out of there all
together so um so there's that the uh D
information uh uh pamphlet has been
compiled at the present time so that
shouldn't be too far away from uh from a
form of release so that they'll sit in
the rsas and certainly in the council
and prominent places so people can
actually learn what it is um what the
Twining situation between uh pendell and
W makad is so uh um because a lot of
people don't know so um few other bits
and pieces but as I say I think I'll um
I think we might get the minutes out to
you there probably a much better way of
informing you than um than me sitting
here rabbiting on just just for members
tonight Pati Andale service is next
Tuesday the 12 11:00 at the Caro senator
for those that are able to attend so
it's um there's quite a a number of
speakers there I see from from um uh
Neil's list that's come here so it's
next Tuesday the 1200 11:00 also the
consulate too yes and the consul's going
to be there too Le burer yeah great uh
regen L thank you um progress um Wales
um bouncy castle for want of a better
name on Courtney lake is progressing the
um bouncy bits are um On The Water
Somewhere Between China and here um they
are hoping to have it up by the end of
October though I can't see that
happening but there it should be up and
running for the summer uh mahunga Kai is
kicking off the paperwork hasn't been
completely finished yet but uh the the
working group aren't waiting for that
they they're meeting um this this week
where we up to jday this this week very
shortly anyway and getting the um and
Kevin has been as as landscaper has been
working on the initial um concept there
um Courtney Hub the detailed plans are
coming back to community board in a
couple of weeks and then going out for
final
consultation uh motor home park is a
little bit stalled with Co and whatever
um they are now not going to be up and
running till uh Grant I think it was
Grant or Chris told me till Fe probably
till February or might have been um
Simon uh they hope they were meant to be
open sort of now for for the summer
doesn't look like they'll make it for
the summer but their um their resource
consents being worked through but the
just the general delays that have hit
hit everybody have hit them so that's me
thanks Al you might want to just about
the Honda planting day that also
happened that
was three weeks ago good
work okay uh climate change and
sustainability Nikki supp there's a few
things that have been going on there um
just last week um Grant McLoud and I met
at ENC to chat to them about a few
things um one of which was composting
food packaging at events so zero waste
events and how they can roll that out um
it's quite heartening to see um where
their where EC's head is at and in that
sustainability space they've really
grabbed the ball they're running with it
uh the um Business Awards will be a
hopefully a zero waste event and it's
going to be all um local uh food
producers M you know their brand made in
North Canterbury um and you know they're
just really grabbing the opportunity
with both hands to do what they can do
their missions footprint and whatnot and
also educate um people whenever they
come to them as small businesses as to
what they can do to be more sustainable
so that's really quite a cool thing so
I'm excited about that um they're doing
a really good job in that space um the
sustainability Champions met last week
and which is the staff group and um also
last week was the um canterburry M
forum's climate change counselor's
Workshop which we had Trevor St stbridge
stuthridge um who is the research
director for egg research and he came
and talked to us about the six areas of
um research that they're working on at
egg research um just basically regarding
um more sustainable farming practices
and and all kinds of interesting things
like the the different ways of um perhap
perhaps reducing methane from from
Kettle and yeah all all sorts of neat
developments there but I think that the
thing that is the most value in those
meetings is actually the opportunity to
network with other um climate change
counselors sort of around the table and
see what their issues and challenges are
where their wins are and where where
their difficulties are so um there was a
very good Round Table conversation that
happened with that and um also I
suppose I will say um where we are at at
the moment we've got a few things going
on but um a district carbon footprint
emissions profile for the the community
emissions profile is is going to be um
commissioned to highlight emission
priorities in the order of magnitud of
reductions needed so basically that's
that's a big job and it's and obviously
it's going to be high level because we
can't possibly go down the rabbit hole
and and figure out everybody's
everything but it'll give us a good idea
where to start um and lastly I would
just like to um say that we are going to
be losing Mike O Connell he has been
poached by the
MF and he will
be um it's a great opportunity for him
and and I'm really sad to lose him
because he has been instrumental in
writing our sustainability strategy and
and helping roll it out he has convened
the the sustainability Champions um
staff group and Been instrumental in
helping me with the sustainability
strategy Steering group and just does an
absolute Untold amount of of um things
in that area that you know whether
whether um acknowledged or not and he
will be a very big loss to us and I I
think we can look at that as an
opportunity or a threat but you know
we've we only have that good gentleman
down at the end of the uh down the end
of the table
Simon Simon in the middle Simon um you
know we've only got him three days a
week he he does an am amazing amount of
work and has a great head on his
shoulders but we've lost Jeff we've
we're losing Mike so um there are boots
to fill big boots and we need to figure
out how we're going to do that and so I
suggest counselors that you put your
minds to that because that is going to
have some big implications well that's
yeah well that's a matter for our chief
executive to reflect on um what you've
just said so um agree with want I say
too much if I haven't already I'll leave
it at that yeah well I agree with you
the loss of those staff members is is is
is huge but to the other organizations
um and wish them well because
particularly U Mike uh he's been superb
and we've been ly absolute horse
Workhorse
okay y I have a question on
sustainability be to the
CEO um would you want to use your
microphone please yeah my concern is we
seem to be a council on The Glass House
throwing
stones okay and that's not really a
question for now can we leave that to
the to the to next week when we have the
counselor catch up with Jim because this
is this is portfolio update really it's
part I'm saying I'd rather it left till
next week thank you
cheers thank you can be raised next week
it's not really the Forum here for that
business promotion and town centers
Jo Sor way thank you um well uh with Co
and lockdowns and things like that we've
had um a joint promotions meeting as
well
as
sorry oh
okay no
worries want the no good good work
thanks thanks Adrian you did a good job
you did a good job all right uh council
do you want to restart yes um well um we
had a joint promotions meeting uh with
um Oxford Caro and
rangiora and um the consensus is that
the businesses um as usual um they're
they're doing okay but not as good as um
the recovery from from last time um but
and then I had a meeting at Enterprise
North Canterbury with visit why maceri
with business owners and um how how we
can do things better and they're saying
that's quite a few businesses are really
struggling so they're they're not as
good as what um has been is being
portrayed out out there in the um in the
media a little bit one of the things
that Enterprise North Country said that
this time with the clo the shutdown done
that they've only had about six people
looking businesses looking for
assistance they they had a lot last year
um but they all seem to know what to do
and how to access um um assistance so
they've theyve they've been not so busy
this time so they're quite pleased about
that um Kaio cultural Festival is H
hoping to happen on the 12th of November
and then on the 12th of March they're
wanting to do the River Parade um also
had meetings with um talking about the
north of High car park building which
we're going to have having a Simon talk
to us about soon so that's okay and um I
was also part of the um Northeast
roading hearing with Paul um the other
day which went very smoothly and we're
very very excited about that um I I have
got I I won't go into that I'll go go
into that with um hia and Cameron so
won't talk about that here um but apart
from that it's um just with the coid
restrictions and everything business
promotions a lot of things are on hold
um and town centers and uh we're just
really on hold until we can actually
open up and and now that we can do more
than a 100 people I suppose it's going
to help and it might help um make our
business Awards hopefully um successful
because we can have more than 100 people
okay so that was on the 20th of November
okay thank you thank you Council any
questions right we're moving no I've got
no questions understanding orders no
agent General business we're going to
move now to matters to be considered
with public excluded the recommendations
there someone prepared to move seconded
by Council Duty um I'll put there it's a
procedual meta all those in favor I
contrary to clear it carried I'll just
give you a moment to update your
computer is into to yep yep so it gives
you a time to turn things
off